İyi akşamlar arkadaşlar. 9 Aralık 2024 Pazartesi günü saat 19.30 46. ders günümüz.
Dersimize başlıyoruz. Kaldığımız yerden devam edeceğiz. Ses ya da görüntüde problem olursa bildirin lütfen değerli arkadaşlar.
Studeray. Evet STL'de gördüğümüz, görmekte olduğumuz son konteyner kendisi Studeray.
Ne yapıyordu? C dizilerini sarmalıyordu. Yani İngilizce ifade edersek a light wrapper over C arrays.
C dizileri üstünde hafif bir sarmalayıcı.
Burada C dizisini doğrudan kullanmak yerine yani array kullanmak yerine Studeray nesneleri kullanarak bazı avantajları elde ediyoruz.
Efficiency açısından bir dezavantajı yok. Ama nerede ya da nerelerde avantajı var?
Arkadaşlar bir interfej sunuyor. Container like bir interfej sunuyor. Array, decay söz konusu değil. Bunun da sağlığı da avantajlar var.
Yine C app'leriyle birlikte kullanılabiliyor.
Fonksiyonlara geçerken bir adres bir de boyut geçmek yerine buradaki Studeray zaten boyutu template argüman olarak aldığı için sadece array nesnesinin kendisini geçmemiz yeterli.
Yeterli. Arkadaşlar exception throw ediyor. Add fonksiyonu, hata yapma riski daha az bir sınıf türü olduğu için konteynerlarda tutulabiliyor.
Ve efendim bir de dizilerin parametreleri bazı durumlarda bir avantaj sağlayabilir.
Genelde kopyalama maliyeti yüzünden istemeyiz ama dizilerin parametreleri Studeray olabiliyor.
Fonksiyonların parametreleri Studeray olabiliyor.
Ve fonksiyonların geri dönüş değeri türü yine dedik ki Studeray olabiliyor.
Arkadaşlar peki nerede kaldığımızı hatırlayalım.
Önce şöyle birkaç hatırlatma cümlesi.
Başlık dosyamız Array.
Yani Studeray'ı kullanmak için Array başlık dosyasını inkolode edecektik.
Burada aslında Array bir structure.
Nasıl? Arkadaşlar bir aggregate type.
Studeray'in birinci template parametresi, dizinin elemanlarının türü ve ikinci template parametresi, dizinin boyutu olan değer.
Array'in int virgül on specialization'ı.
Tabii ki örneğin şöyle iki Array nesnesi oluştursam bunlar farklı türlerden nesneler.
Birbirlerini initialize edemezler, birbirlerine atanamazlar.
Türleri aynı değil.
Yani ister birinci template parametresine karşılık gelen template argümanı farklı tür olsun, ister ikinci template parametresine karşılık gelen non-type argümanı farklı olsun, farklı Array türleri oluşuyor değerli arkadaşlar.
Evet, ilk değer verebiliyoruz ama burada ilk değer verdiğimizde aggregate initialization söz konusu oluyor dedik.
Bu bir aggregate olduğu için default initialize edildiğinde çok değerler indetermined value'larla hayata geliyor.
Fakat value initialize ettiğimizde aritmetik türden elemana sahip Array nesnelerinin değeri sıfır oluyor, değerleri sıfır oluyor dedik.
Arkadaşlar, sitattan faydalanabiliriz eleştirilen bir durum ama aslında teknik olarak bir engel olmasa da örneğin Array nesnesini bu şekilde oluşturduğunda
derleyici buradaki öğelerden, ilk değer veren öğelerin türünün int olduğundan ve 5 tane initializer olduğundan Array'in int virgül 5 specialization olduğunu anlıyor.
Ama açısal parantez kullanırsak maalesef syntax hatası.
Açısal parantez kullanıp dizinin elemanlarının türünü yazarsak yine syntax hatası olduğunu söyledik.
Arkadaşlar, dedik ki şu kalsın Array to pointer conversion yok.
Yani, örneğin böyle bir Array int 5 söz konusuysa, int yıldız p eşittir a, syntax hatası normal dizlerdeki Array to pointer conversion ya da Array decay dediğimiz özellikle koru da tabii ki yok.
Zaten varlık nedenlerinden biri de bu.
A, illa ki, bu da güzel bir söz değil mi Türkçe'de, illa ki eğer ben dizinin ilk elemanının adresini kullanmak istiyorsam sınıfın beta fonksiyonunu çağırabilirim.
Ya da köşeli parantez operatör fonksiyonuyla dizinin ilk elemanına erişip onun adres operatörüyle adresini alabilirim.
Hatta hatta bu bir artık SQL container olduğu için arkadaşlar begin fonksiyonunu çağırıp bu iteratör konumundaki öğeğe dereferencing operatörüyle erişip onun da adres operatörüyle adresini alabilirim.
Arkadaşlar CIP'lerine doğrudan data fonksiyonunun arkadaşlar, geçen kaldığımız yerde sanırım burasıydı, data fonksiyonunun geri dönüş değeri olan adresi ve dizinin boyutu olarak template argümanını veren size fonksiyonuna çağrı yapabilirim.
Jenerik kodlarda bazen gerekebiliyor dedik.
İstersem array'in arkadaşlar herhangi bir tür örneğin int virgül sıfır açılımı dahi geçerli bir tür.
Empty fonksiyonunu çağırdığımda empty fonksiyonu true verecek.
Size fonksiyonunu çağırdığımda size fonksiyonu sıfır döndürecek.
Front ya da back fonksiyonlarına çağrı yaptığımda arkadaşlar anımsız davranış olacak.
Begin iteratörü end iteratörüne eşit olacak ve bu iteratörleri d-referens etmem yine anımsız davranış olacak.
Array bir sınıf bugünkü derse yetişir umarım.
Tuple interface'ini sağladığı için aslında bir sınıf olmasına rağmen tuple interface'ini sağladığı için
arkadaşlar bu tuple interface ile kullandığımız structure binding'de de kullanabiliyorum.
Ve bir konteyner olduğu için range-based for loop'da da kullanabiliyorum.
Yani örneğin ereğin int virgül dört açılımı are
ya da ereğin int virgül üç açılımı olsun
auto x, y, z eşittir a, r
ya da referans emantiği ile
auto ref x, y, z eşittir a, r
artı artı artı artı x, artı artı y, artı artı z ve range-based for loop'a uygunluğunda gösterelim.
for const orta yada int i
range-based for loop'a uygunluğunda
are final stream
.
Evet gördüğünüz gibi 4, 6, 8 çünkü referans emantiği ile range-based for loop'la eriştim.
Bir konteyner olduğu için tabii ki STL algoritmalarıyla random access iteratör kategorisine sahip bir konteyner aynı zamanda örneğin ereğin biraz yazalım int virgül on açılımı are
ve arkadaşlar ve diyelim ki range-based for loop ya da köşeli parantez operatör fonksiyonu
arkadaşlar size b i eşit 0, i küçük 10 ya da are'nin size'ı artı artı artı i neutrity
Aşık dosyasını ekleyelim ve
ar köşeli parantez i eşittir
Arkadaşlar
i rent my rent
tıpır
ar köşeli parantez i eşittir
my rent
Süper
Biraz
Yine
hatırlatma yapalım
köşeli parantez operatör fonksiyonu
indeksin
hatalı yanlış olması durumunda
geçerli bir indeks olmaması durumunda
Yine
arkadaşlar
exception
prove etmiyor
tanımsız davranış
ama burada
at fonksiyonunu çağırırsam
indeksin geçerli olması durumunda
stood out of range
exception'i
throw ediyor
demiştik
Arkadaşlar
şimdi
algoritm
başlık dosyasını
dahil edelim
Arkadaşlar bu arada
size söylememiş olabilirim
benim kurucusu olduğum bu
Türkiye C++ topluluğunda duyurusunu yaptım
yanlış hatırlamıyorsam
biraz hatırlamam gerekiyor ama
pazar günü olması gerekir
bu C++ 20 standartıyla bile eklenen konseptleri anlatacağım
herkese açık
bir ders ya da sunum
artık ne dersiniz olacak
burada da ben kesin tarih ve saatimi
telegram grubundan da bizim kursun telegram grubundan da bildirebilirim
zamanı olan arkadaşlar
izleyebilirler
zira konseptler C++ 20 bizim bu kursumuza süre kısıtlaması nedeniyle
sürenin yetersizliği nedeniyle dahil değil
ileri C++ kursunda katılmak isteyen arkadaşlar
davetli bakacak
takılabilirler diyelim
şimdi efendim
algoritm başlık dosyasında
bunun da bir konteyner olduğu vurgusunu
biraz daha kuvvetlendirmek için
örneğin
status sort'u çağıralım
ve sort'a
are'nin
begin'i
are'nin end'ini
argüman olarak geçelim sort algoritmasını
biliyoruz
değil mi
evet
arkadaşlar
ve
hatta
şöyle bir şey yapalım
bir de
for each algoritmasını
çalıştıralım
buraya da
are begin
for each herkes hatırlıyor değil mi
are end
ve
bir
lambda
ifadesi
arkadaşlar
int x
hatta int ref x
return x
mod
bölü
eşit
yani
önce
sort algoritmasıyla
büyükten küçüğe sır
küçükten büyüğe sıraladım
sonra da
for each algoritmasıyla
döngünün
her turunda
nesnemizin değerini
10'da
birini getirdim
ondan sonra
hadi bakalım
bir for each
daha çalıştıralım
for each
ve
bu seferde
are begin
are end
biraz
algoritma tekrar da
yapmış oluruz
lambda ifadesi
int x
arkadaşlar
ve
tut
see out
x
evet
üç tane
algoritmaya
peş peşe çağrı yaptık
sort
bir tane
for each
sonuçta
stodereyde
bir
konteyner
değil mi
evet
arkadaşlar
ekran çıktığımıza
bakalım
evet
yirmi dokuz
otuz iki
elli bir
burada
evet
bu
bunun
bugün
mekan çıktısı
değil
evet
bakalım şimdi
are
i eşittir
my round
şurada
are begin
are end
return
x
bölü eşit
on
are end
see out
x
evet
derledim
ve
çalıştırdım
tamam
şimdi oldu
bunu da şimdilik
örneklerimize
koyalım
ve
studeriyle ilgili
konuşmaya devam edelim
arkadaşlar
şimdi
array sonuçta
bir sınıf şablonu
cennelik bir sınıf
örneğin
array'in
int virgül 5
açıldı mı
o bir
sınıf
yani bir
sınıf şablonunun
bir
class template'in
bir specialization'ı
eğer
instantiate edilirse
sonuçta o da
kanlı canlı
bir sınıf
değil mi
dolayısıyla
biz
empty
argümanı olarak da
kullanabiliriz
mesela bakın
array'in int virgül 10
açılımı bu bir
specialization
örneğin
sadece geçerli olduğunu
görmeniz için
vektörün
array'in int virgül
specialization'ı
neden olmasın
ama daha da ilginç
iki boyutlu diziyi
temsil etmesi için
arkadaşlar
şöyle de yazabilirsiniz
değil mi
array'in
array'in int virgül
10 virgül
açılımı
örneğin
arkadaşlar
stud array'in
int virgül
açılımı
ama
bu da
yine array'e
birinci template argümanı olsun
ve
arkadaşlar
burada
belki biraz tuhaf gelebilir
ona anlatmayı
bir başka derste bırakırsam
biraz o
yüzüyor beni
o tarafa anlatmak
çok zaman gidiyor
ama bakın burada
maalesef
dışta iki tane
küme parantez olmak zorunda
şimdi
elemanlara ihtiyar veriyorum
örneğin
bu
4 elemanlı
dizimizin
array'in
nesnemizin
ilk elemanını
initialize edecek
efendim
kolaylık
akip edin diye
arkadaşlar
ve
şurada
bir küme parantezi
bazı oldu
evet
arkadaşlar
şurada
evet
tamam
bir de
süper
ve
küme parantezlerini
kapattım
buraya kadar
derleyelim
hatta şimdi
geçen derste yazdık mı
hatırlamıyorum
yazmıştık galiba
bir tane
insörter yazalım
template
typename t
stud
size t
n
stud
o stream
red
operatör
left
shift
stud
o stream
rev
os
ans
stud
array'in
p
virgül
n
açılımı
rev
are
işte
yazdık
şimdi
os
köşeli parantez
şöyle bir kod
yazmıştım
for
stud
size
t
i
eşit
küçük
are'nin
size'ı
eksi
plus plus
i
ve
os
parantez
o r köşeli parantez
i
arkadaşlar
ee
bir
virgül
boşluk
ee
döngüden çıktığında
hatta tamam şimdi hatırladım
bir arkadaşım
dedi ki buraya
boyut 0 olan dizi gelirse
hata olur demiştim
ben de haklısınız demiştim
konuda
düzeltip buraya bir
statik i
yani
if constexpr'e koymuştuk
ama şimdi bu
boş olan dizilere
yüz vermesin
kaybetmeyelim
os
arkadaşlar
are
back
köşeli parantezi
kapatsın
evet
ve şimdi
see out
are
köşeli parantez 3
dizinin
ya da
ar
bir
retor
statement
unuttuk
onu
ekledik
maşallah
herhangi bir hata yok
ve gördüğünüz gibi
gayet de güzel
yazdırdı
arkadaşlar şimdi bakın
mesela
are
köşeli parantez 3
dizinin
ya da are
köşeli parantez 2
dizinin
iki indizli
elemanı
bu da bir
studeray
int virgül 3
nesnesi
onun
örneğin
bir indizli
elemanına
bu şekilde
yetişebilirim
tabi ki burada
aslında yapılan şu
değil mi
are'nin
operatör köşeli parantezi
yine
yani yukarıdaki kodla
aşağıdaki kod
birbirine
eş değer
diyebiliriz
efendim
başka
neler var
CIP'lerine
argüman olarak
gönderilir
dedik
orada bir
herhangi bir şekilde
bir problemimiz yok
sitattan
faydalandığını söyledik
eksik bir şey kaldı
mı diye düşünüyorum
arkadaşlar
onun dışında
ha
taşıma semantiğinden
şu şekilde
faydalanıyor
yani
elemanları
taşınabilir
türdense
taşıma semantiğinden
are'i de
faydalanıyor
tabi ki
are'i de ekleme
silme işlemleri yok
çünkü sonuçta
cd'sinde
ekleme
silme işlemi yok
arkadaşlar
taşıma semantiğine
bir örnek
verelim
mesela
string başlık dosyasını
dahil edelim
ere'in
string
virgül
beş
dört açılımı
are
ve
mustafa
gökalp
ayşegül
nagehan
gül ya
dört
dört oldu zaten
şimdi
ere'i
arkadaşlar
bakın bazen
tür bilgisi yazmak zor
saçında
bir de yapabilirim
değil mi?
örneğin
teka type are
are'nin türü demek
ister böyle yazayım
ister aynı türü yazayım
ben istersem
auto
are
hadi bu da
are 1 olsun
eşittir
arkadaşlar
stud
move
are
are 2
için
move
konstruktör çalışacak
konstruktör
diğer
studeley nesnesinin
elemanlarını alırken
bizim elemanları
arkadaşlar
ne yapacak
move
konstruktör edecek
dolayısıyla
şimdi
are 2
yazdırdığımda
for
const
auto
buraya kadar
derleyelim
evet
ama diğerini dolaşayım
are 1
move
from state
olduğunu göstermek
için
length
fonksiyonunu
çağırayım
tabi
garanti altında değil
ama
konuşmuştuk
tipik olarak
move
from state
string
nesneleri
borç yazı
tutuyor
durumdalar
evet
tabi
bunu şöyle de
gösterebilirdik
class
net
biraz
move tekrar
yapalım
ya da
struct net
page
people
constructor
copy
yap
constructor
Evet
Fiyat, copy, constructor, add.
Yine move constructor, match, rep, move constructor, diğer memberleri göstermiyorum ve array'in match, 4 açılımı.
Böyle default constructor edilecek, array'in match, 4 açılımı, ar2 eşittir, ar1, pop constructor, move ar1.
Bu kez gördüğünüz gibi move constructor'ın çağrıldığını görüyoruz.
Bunu da tekrar bir göstermek istiyorum.
Necbir, 0 açılımı, Google Alfa, Cout, Cout, Ar, iki tane var zaten.
Empty ve tabii ki template parametresini, karşılık gelen template argümanını döndüren size fonksiyonu o da 0 döndürecek.
Başka neyi gösterdik, fonksiyonun geri dönüş değeri, stud array türü olabilir.
Yani referans ya da pointer türü olmadan, stud array'in int virgül 3 açılımı,
Bu, return int x, int y, int z, return x, y, v, hatta foto, arkadaşlar, abc.
A, b, c, eşittir, u, 1, 4, 6.
Herhangi bir şekilde bir syntax hatası yok.
Fonksiyonun geri dönüş değeri, stud array türüünden ve structured binding ile ne yaptım?
Arkadaşlar, öğelerine ayrıştırdım.
Evet, arkadaşlar, başka, ha, şimdi C++20 ile burası biraz karmaşık gelebilir.
To array isimli bir fonksiyon eklendi, arkadaşlar.
Yani, aslında, önemli string literalinden, to array fonksiyonu ile bir dizi elde edebiliyorum.
Bu, çenerik kodlar da fayda sağlıyor.
Örneğin, bir arkadaşımın ismini seçeyim.
Evet, Cengizhan.
Mesela, stud, two array.
Arkadaşlar, bakın, aslında, two array.
Görüyorsunuz, bir kendisi.
Hamlet.
Şu ipucunu görebiliyorsunuz, değil mi?
Evet.
Type name t'ye, size t'ye size.
Arkadaşlar, array'i alıyor.
Ve, geri dönüş değeri.
İzleyin.
E tabi, birden fazla overloadu var.
Yani, şöyle çağırabiliyorum, özetle.
Ama, şu anda, çok da bizim için önemli değil.
Two array'e, örneğin, çift ırnak içinde, Cengizhan.
Şimdi, geri dönüş değerine bakın.
O, a, re, eşittir.
A, re'nin türüne bakın.
Arkadaşlar.
Aray'in, çar virgül, on açılımı.
Yani, örneğin, for, çar, c, are, stud, c, out, c.
Evet, initializer list de kullanabilirim.
Örneğin, bu sefer de, query.
Ve, bu, çok jenerik programlama tarafı için.
Mesela, iki, iki, üç, beş, yedi, on bir, on üç.
A, re'nin türünün, arkadaşlar, görüyorsunuz.
A, re'nin, int virgül, altı açılımı olduğunu, oto, konst, oto, i, are ve i dizinin elemanlarına erişebilirim.
Böylece, su dereyle ilgili konuştukları, konuşacaklarımızı konuşmuş olduk.
Çinlik programlama tarafına biraz ağırlık verebiliriz ama henüz erken dereyle ilgili.
Arkadaşlar, şimdi bakalım menüye neler gelmiş.
Arkadaşlar, şimdi biz konteyner grubunu bitirdik.
Ama, aslında konteyner olmayan, bir şekilde böyle konteynerımsı görüntü veren bazı SDR sınıfları var.
Şimdi bunlardan üçü, bunlara konteyner adaptörleri deniyor.
İngilizce, konteyner adaptörs.
Bunlar, üç tane temel, abstract data type'ı temsil eden jenerik sınıflar.
Biri stud stack, bir yeri arkadaşlar stud q, bir yeri de stud priority q.
Bunları hemen göreceğiz.
Bunlar kolay.
Zaten, priority q'yu algoritmalar konusunda keep algoritmalarını anlatırken biraz konuşmuştuk.
Arkadaşlar, önlükünü anlamamız gerekiyor.
Bunlar konteyner değil.
Bunlara konteyner adaptörü deniyor.
Ben adaptör, İngilizce adaptör sözlüğünün Türkçe karşılığı olarak uyumlandırıcı terimini kullanıyorum.
Aslında bu anlamda adaptör ne demek?
Özellikle design patterns konusuna geldiğinizde,
orada adaptör patternini zaten yoğun kullanacaksınız ya da kullanmışsınızdır.
Arkadaşlar, aslında iki partlı adaptör patterni var.
Biri doğrudan kompozisyon yoluyla, diğeri de statik türe bağlı olarak.
Bir sınıf türünden nesneyi alıyoruz.
O nesnenin ilişkin olduğu sınıfın interfezini kendi amaçlarımız doğrultusunda, adı üstünde adapte ediyoruz.
Burada,
şimdi stack nedir, q nedir, priority q nedir herkes biliyor ama çok kısa bir açıklama da yapabilirim.
Örneğin biz bir vektör konteynerına eleman olarak alsak,
vektörün interfezinde bir sürü fonksiyon var.
Fakat biz stack interfezi sunmak istiyoruz.
Stack interfezinde ne var?
Siteye push yaparsınız, stackten pop yaparsınız,
stackten en üstteki V'ye erişirsiniz,
V sayısına bakarsınız vs.
İşte aslında böyle bir sınıf yazarak
eleman olarak aldığımız bir konteynerın interfezini
adapte ederek bir stack interfezi oluşturabiliriz.
İşte bu sınıflar böyle.
Gerek stack, gerek q, gerek arkadaşlar priority q.
Bunlar sınıf şablonları ama bunlar konteyner değil.
Örneğin bunların iteratör veren fonksiyonları var mı?
Cevap hayır.
Bunlar sadece temsil ettikleri data structure'ın,
hatta daha güzeltelim abstract data type'a uygun bir interfez veriyorlar.
Stack bildiğimiz gibi arkadaşlar son girenin ilk çıktığı,
yani last in first out,
kuyruk ilk girenin ilk çıktığı,
first in first out,
öncelik kuyruğu priority q,
ne sırayla girerse girsin,
önceliği yüksek olanın ilk çıktığı abstract data type'lar.
stack, stack başlık dosyasında,
q ve priority q için ayrı header'lar yok.
Hem q hem priority q bunlar arkadaşlar q başlık dosyasında.
görece olarak küçük sınıflar birkaç tane üye fonksiyonları var.
Kullanımları son derece pratik.
Bu da demek ki stack kullanmak istiyorsanız bir veri yapısı olarak.
Arkadaşlar mesela bu mülakatlarda biliyorsunuz artık firmaların çoğu programlama dilinden bağımsız,
bu hacker rank, codility, lead code gibi sitelerden problem çözdürüyorlar.
Orada C++ programcıları o tür sorularda çok daha avantajlı.
C++ diline hakimse ve özellikle de STL'i iyi kullanıyorsa,
verili beceri seviyesindeyse,
algoritmalar hakkında da fikir sahibiyse,
burada veri yapıları ve algoritmalar hazır geldiği için,
çok daha kısa sürede oradaki problemleri arkadaşlar çözebiliyor.
Mesela C ile çözmek çok daha zor.
Çünkü veri yapıları hazır gelmediği için.
Orada örneğin birçok soruda bir stack oluşturmanız
ya da bir kuyruk ya da bir öncelik kuyruğu oluşturmanız gerektiğinde
burada hazır bizim stack q, priority q sınıflarımızı kullanabilirsiniz.
İlk giren, son giren ilk çıkar stack, ilk giren ilk çıkar kuyruk, q, önceliği yüksek olan önce çıkar.
O da arkadaşlar priority q biliyorsunuz.
Biz bunları tek tek ele alacağız ama hızlı bir şekilde.
hemen, evet programlamada en sık kullanılan abstract data type,
soyut veri yapısı diyorum ben, soyut veri yapılarından biri stack.
Arkadaşlar, şimdi bu data structures and algorithms konusunda
tam bir terimsel birlik yok.
Yani farklı kişiler terimleri biraz daha farklı yorumlayabiliyorlar.
Mesela sizce, siz kendi fikrinizi söyleyin, data structure'la
ADT diye kısal plan, abstract data type arasında sizce
A bunlar aynı şey, B hayır, aynı şey değil.
Çünkü farklı yorumlayanlar var.
Bu soruya siz cevap verin, ben de kendi cevabımı vereyim.
Benim kendi cevabım, bu terimlerin farklı anlamlara geldiği yönde.
En azından ben farklı anlam yüklüyorum.
Abstract data type dediğiniz zaman,
implementasyondan bağımsız bir interfej kastediyorsunuz.
En azından ben böyle kastediyorum.
Mesela stack.
Stack bir abstract data type mı?
Evet.
Arkadaşlar, mesela stack veri yapısından bahsettiğim zaman,
siteyin nasıl implemente edilmesiyle bunun bir ilgisi var mı?
Hayır, bir interfejden bahsediyorum.
Örneğin, class arkadaşlar, stack, sözde böyle bir sınıf olsa,
diyorum ki, alın dostlar, size bir interfej.
Siteye push fonksiyonunu çağırarak bir pump sayıyı siteye alabilirsiniz, sokabilirsiniz.
Türkçe-İngilizce tabiriyle, arkadaşlar, Türk-English ile push edebilirsiniz.
Efendim, stackten en üsttekini çıkartabilirsiniz.
Efendim, en üsttekine erişebilirsiniz.
steyin size'ını, yani kaç tane öğe olduğunu,
get fonksiyonuyla, arkadaşlar, öğrenebilirsiniz.
Size, size fonksiyonuyla.
Öğrenin, bakın ben size bir interfej sunuyorum şu anda, değil mi?
Arkadaşlar, stut, size, t, size.
Efendim, boşalık olmadığını, boğul, empty, const, böyle bir fonksiyonla sınayabilirsiniz.
Arkadaşlar, işte böyle, belki bir iki tane fonksiyon da ekleyebilirim.
Ben size bir interfej sunmuş oluyorum.
Ama şimdi bu interfej size, steyin nasıl implemente edildiğini anlatıyor mu?
Cevap, cevap, hayır.
Ben, belki bir cdc kullanıyor olabilirim.
Belki bir link list kullanıyor olabilirim.
Belki bir vektör ya da deck kullanıyor olabilirim.
Bu bir interfej sadece.
Ama, mesela link list böyle değil.
Ben, örneğin size, doubly link list veri yapısından bahsettiğim zaman,
hemen sizin aklınıza, efendim, node'lar olacak.
Node'ların içinde iki tane pointer olacak.
Pointer'lardan biri, daha önceki, sekanstaki, daha önceki öğeyi tutan node'u gösterecek.
Vesaire vesaire.
İşte bakın, o implementasyonu da içerik.
O yüzden ben stack, queue ve priority queue sınıfları için bunlara arkadaşlar abstract data type diyorum.
Hangi programda mı dili olursa olsun.
Peki, bizim sevgili s diyelimizde stack nasıl bir jenerik sınıf?
Arkadaşlar, burası biraz size tuhaf gelebilir.
Ama, aslında şöyle, bakın, iki tane template parametresi var.
Birinci template parametresi, stack'te tutulacak öğenin türü.
Yani aslında, biraz daha flexibility, esneklik istenmeseydi,
stack sınıf şablonu pekala böyle olabilirdi.
Yani, stack'te int tutacaksanız, stack'in int specialization'ını, string tutacaksanız, stack'in string specialization'ını kullanabilirdiniz.
Ama, s diyelim şöyle bir karar vermiş, şöyle bir olanak sağlıyor.
İkinci bir template parametresi var.
İkinci template parametresi,
stack'in, arkadaşlar, bir container'ı eleman olarak edinip,
onun interfeysini adapte edecek ya,
diyor ki, container'ı sen seç, sevgili kullanıcı kod.
Dolayısıyla, ikinci bir template parametresi var.
Stack'te adapte edilecek,
interfeysi adapte edilecek,
container'ın türü,
ama, ilginç bir şekilde,
bu da, ne alıyor, arkadaşlar?
Stut,
DQ'nun,
e-açılım.
Ve böylece,
ne sağlanıyor, arkadaşlar?
Burada,
işte,
eleman olarak alınan,
container'ın türü,
ikinci template parametresi türünde.
C,
C.
Arkadaşlar,
bu arada,
elemanı,
protected yaptığıma dikkat edin.
Ve C ismini verdiğime dikkat edin.
Gerçekten de,
S-TL'deki stack'te,
container'ımız,
sınıfın protected member'ı,
ve C ismiyle,
stack sınıfından,
aynı durum,
priority Q ve Q için de geçerli,
stack sınıfından,
kalıtım yoluyla,
kendi stack sınıfınızı oluşturduğunuzda,
taban sınıfının,
protected data member'ı,
container elemana,
erişmeniz mümkün.
İşte burada da,
birazdan göreceğiz,
stack için sunulmuş,
bir interfeys var.
Bu da şu demek,
tekrar,
stack başlık dosyasını bu sefer,
dahil edelim,
ve arkadaşlar,
diyelim ki,
örneğin,
stack int açılımı,
istiyorsanız,
ve container olarak,
back alınmasına,
bir itirazınız yoksa,
ki,
bir iki,
istisnai senaryo haricinde,
itirazınız olmamalı,
böyle bir,
stack nesnesi,
oluşturabilirsiniz.
takip edebiliyor muyuz?
Stain int açılımı,
my stack.
Ama aslında,
stain int açılımı,
my stack ne demek?
Stain int virgül,
deck'in,
int açılımı,
my stack demek.
Değil mi?
Ama burada,
deck'in int specializationı,
merkör,
ne olarak geliyor?
Default,
pamphlet argument olarak,
geliyor.
Ama ben,
örneğin,
arkadaşlar,
bir,
vektör,
elemanı,
edinmek isteseydim,
bu sefer,
stain int virgül,
deck'in,
int açılımı demek yerine,
burada,
stut vektörün,
int açılımı,
diyecektim.
Ya da,
örneğin,
sürekli,
kendi stacklerimde,
container olarak,
Necati her container'ı alabilir miyiz?
Hayır.
Çünkü burada,
arkadaşlar,
sınıfın,
back fonksiyonu,
pushback fonksiyonu,
kullanıldığı için,
burada,
back pushback fonksiyonlarının,
olması,
gerekiyor.
Container'in,
gerekli şartları,
sağlayabilmesi için,
oraya geleceğiz.
Ya da,
bir,
türeşizim bildirimi,
yapabilirsiniz.
Örneğin,
diyebilirsiniz ki,
arkadaşlar,
template,
tightening t,
efendim,
using,
restack,
eşittir,
stut,
pekin,
p virgül,
stut vektörün,
p açılımı.
söyleyin bakalım,
bu yaptığım bildirime ne deniyor?
Kimler unuttu,
kimler unutmadı?
Unutmayanlar buraya gelsin.
Sohbet ekranı boş kaldı,
dolduralım lütfen.
Burada kullandığım,
sentak söylesine ne deniyordu?
ne template'i?
Cevap,
alias template.
Bravo,
bravo, bravo,
alias template.
Evet.
Şimdi,
eğer ben sürekli,
vektörün kullanılmasını istiyorsam,
her defasında,
tekrar etmek yerine,
Yiğitinci,
Oğuzhan,
Esin,
Muhammed,
Teşekkür ederim.
Alias template'i,
we stack'i kullanabilirim.
Arkadaşlar,
doğrusunu söylemek gerekirse,
ben,
kendi kodlarımda,
stek kullandığım zaman,
beki tercih etmediğim,
tek bir senaryo var.
Yani normal,
dekimli,
sakıncası olduğunu da düşünmüyorum.
Ama,
ilginç bir şey var,
bakınız,
bakalım fark edebilecek misiniz?
Constructor,
stay'in konstruktör'ı,
vektörün,
efendim,
int açılımı,
vektör,
şimdi izleyin bakalım,
bir sonuç çıkartacak mısınız?
Ben konuşmayayım,
kodum konuşsun,
siz kodumdan,
bir sonuç çıkartın.
Efendim,
dek başlık dosyasını,
zaten stek dahil ediyor.
Dek,
dek,
o da aynı olsun.
burada artık,
milyonlarca kez konuştuğumuz için,
sted'in etkin olduğunu,
c++ 17 gerektirdiğini söyleyelim.
Arkadaşlar,
stay'in,
stek'in,
öyle demek gerekiyor değil mi?
int açılımı,
st1,
efendim,
dek,
st'in,
int açılımı,
st2,
vek.
Arkadaşlar,
st,
ikinci template olarak kullanılan,
konteyner literatürde,
underline container olarak bir isimlendiriliyor.
Dolayısıyla isterseniz,
ben,
underline container,
elimini,
burada hiç kullanıldığını görmedim.
Ama bakın,
stay'in inti,
container type diye bir nested type var.
Underline type kullanılabilir mi?
Underline container,
bence kullanılabilir.
Yani gayet de güzel karşılıyor.
Ama kullanıldığını Necati sen gördün mü?
Ben görmedim.
ama kullanılması,
bana son derece doğal geliyor.
Çünkü,
gerçekten,
underline container ya da,
member container belki diyebiliriz.
Ama,
Cengizan Bey,
böyle bir nested type var.
Yani,
st,
int açılımının konteynerı,
eleman olarak edinilen konteyner.
Şimdi siz bana söyleyin.
Şair,
coder bu koduyla ne demek istiyor?
Şunu tahmin ediyorsunuz değil mi?
Coder bu koduyla,
15. satırdaki,
st2'nin tanımının,
sentaks hatası olduğunu söylüyor.
Bravo,
bravo,
yiğit.
Yani,
arkadaşlar,
sınıfın aslında bir,
bir konstruktörü var.
Bu konstruktör bir konteyner istiyor.
Ama,
konstruktörün istediği konteyner,
member olan konteyner türünden.
İşte,
ben de bunu anlatmak istedim yiğit.
Dedim ki,
ben,
vektör steğini,
ancak bu koşulda kullanıyorum.
Yani,
indimde zaten bir vektör var.
Ben,
bu vektördeki öğeleri,
stekte kullanmak istiyorum.
O zaman,
default template argümanını kullandığımda,
bunu yapamıyorum.
Ama,
arkadaşlar,
şöyle yazdığımda,
işte,
stekin,
int virgül,
vektörün,
int açılımı,
my stack,
ve,
vek dediğinde,
bunu yapabiliyorum.
Herkes anladı mı?
nereye gönderme yaptığımı.
Bence,
bu deck dışında,
ikinci bir,
template argümanı,
vektör kullanmaya,
tek neden demiyorum,
şüphesiz farklı tercihler olabilir.
Ama,
önemli nedenlerden biri,
bence bu böyle bir konteynerın olması.
Şimdi,
biz,
steyimize,
stekimize,
geri dönelim.
stekin,
ve,
arkadaşlar,
int açılımı,
my stack.
Şimdi,
bakın,
son derece basit bir interfej var.
Yalnız,
ilginç bir şekilde,
C ve C++ dillerinde,
stek,
C'de de böyledir,
hep geleneksel olarak,
stek interfejsi,
nedense,
Java,
C şart gibi dillerden,
önemli bir farklılık gösterir.
Aynı farklılık,
arkadaşlar,
Q,
ve priority Q'da da var.
şimdi,
diğer programlama dillerinde,
genelde,
şöyle bir yapı var.
Burayı,
biraz dikkatli izlerseniz,
itirazlarınızı da bana iletebilirsiniz.
Şöyle bir,
arkadaşlar,
interfejsi var.
C++ da böyle değil,
ya da C kütüphaneleri de,
çoğunlukla böyle değil.
Şimdi,
biliyorsunuz,
stekte ki,
iki tane,
üç tane önemli işlem var.
bir siteye push yapmak,
yani son gireni sokmak,
girditmek,
artık ne derseniz,
buna nasıl bir fiil oldu,
girditmek,
bir şey mi?
kullanmak,
stekte ki,
boş.
Arkadaşlar,
ondan sonra,
pub fonksiyonu,
en üstteki öğeye erişmek,
ve,
ilk öğeyi,
yani,
en üstteki öğeyi,
son çıkanı çıkartmak için de,
pub fonksiyonu.
Fakat,
programlama dillerinin,
hemen hepsinde,
CC,
pas,
pas haricinde,
pub fonksiyonu,
void fonksiyonu değildir.
Yani,
siz pub fonksiyonunu çağırdığınız zaman,
geri dönüş değeri olarak,
pub fonksiyonundan,
zaten,
top değerini elde edersiniz.
Yani,
bakınız,
örneğin,
int stek ise,
pub fonksiyonunun,
arkadaşlar,
bildiriminin böyle olduğunu düşünün.
Stekte ki öğeyi çıkartıyor,
ama,
aynı zamanda,
geri dönüş değeriyle,
en üsttekine,
get etmiş oluyorsunuz.
Yani,
iki işi birden yapıyor.
Hem get ediyor,
hem pop ediyor.
Fakat,
bizde böyle değil.
Bizde,
genel eğilim,
C'de de,
C++'da da,
pop'un,
geri dönüş değerinin olmaması.
Yani,
pop sadece,
arkadaşlar,
o üstünde,
popping yapıyor.
Stekten,
ya da veri yapısından,
öğeyi çıkartıyor.
Dolayısıyla,
örneğin,
stekteki,
bütün öğeylerin değerini,
get edip,
ondan sonra onu çıkartacaksanız,
tek bir fonksiyon çağrısı değil.
İki tane,
arkadaşlar,
fonksiyon çağrısı yapıyorsunuz.
Evet,
evet,
ben sorunuzu kaçırdım mı,
Yiğit,
vekili,
yeni yapabilmek için,
evet,
onu anlattım zaten.
İkinci,
tertek parametresine,
konteyner açılımını,
yazmak zorundasınız.
Tekrar buraya geri dönelim.
Dolayısıyla,
biz de,
pop void function,
pop ise,
referans döndürüyor.
Bunun böyle yapılmasının nedeni,
arkadaşlar,
aksi halde,
exception safety'nin sağlanamaması,
genel açıklama bu.
İkincisi,
STL'deki,
stack,
Q ve priority Q,
exception prove etmiyor.
C-sharp,
Java gibi dillerin,
standart kütüphanelerindeki,
benzer sınıflar,
örneğin,
stack boş iken,
stack'te,
top ya da,
top işlemi yapmanız,
exception prove etmesine,
neden oluyor.
Fakat bizde,
bunlar,
sunumsuz davranış.
Yani,
boş stack'ten,
top işlemi yapmayın.
Yaparsanız,
herhangi bir şekilde,
exception prove etmiyor.
Undefined behavior,
yine,
top ya da,
top fonksiyonları,
bu karakterde değil.
İşte o nedenle,
eğer,
gerçekten,
yok,
ben alıştım,
ya da bazı nedenlerden,
benim pop'um,
aynı zamanda,
değeri get etsin diyorsanız,
kendi stack sınıfınızı,
kendiniz yazacaksınız.
En fazla,
40-50 satırlık,
bir sınıf,
son derece basit,
beraber de yazarız.
Arkadaşlar,
bizimki,
exception prove etmiyor,
aynı zamanda dedik.
Exception prove etmesini istiyorsanız,
yine,
kendi stack sınıfınızı,
kendiniz,
yazmalısınız,
onu söyleyelim.
Şimdi efendim,
bizim interfezimizi görelim.
Son derece basit.
Bakınız,
hepsine örnek vereceğim.
Arkadaşlar,
ben,
önem sırasına göre söyleyeyim.
Push etmek için,
push fonksiyonu.
Görüyorsunuz,
geri dönüş değeri yok,
ve arkadaşlar,
tabii ki,
L value,
const L value,
R value,
referans,
overloadu var,
saçma semantiği için.
Up fonksiyonuyla,
stackteki,
en üstteki,
öğeyi,
çıkartıyorsunuz.
Stack boş değilse,
çağırmıyorsunuz.
Void fonksiyonu olduğuna,
dikkat edin.
Top ettikten sonra,
artık o değeri,
kaçırmış,
olursunuz.
Up fonksiyonu,
stackteki,
en üstteki,
öğeyi,
referans semantiğiyle,
eriştiriyor.
Tabii ki,
const overload edilmiş.
Const overloadingde,
hangi anlamda kullandığımı,
daha önce,
defalarca,
anlatmıştım.
Bunun dışında,
empty fonksiyonu,
arkadaşlar,
yine,
ne yapıyor?
Stack boş mu sorusuna cevap veriyor.
Size fonksiyonu,
stackteki,
öğeyi sayısını,
get ediyor.
Bir de,
ne var?
Arkadaşlar,
efendim,
swap fonksiyonu,
C++ 20 ile gelen,
push range fonksiyonu,
onları anlatmayacağım.
Swap'ı zaten söylemeye gerek yok.
Bir de,
emplace fonksiyonu var.
Arkadaşlar,
zaten bakın,
stack dediğiniz nedir ki?
anın,
beraber,
bir tane,
stack sınıfı yazalım.
Yani,
3-4 satır,
demeyelim de,
20-30 satır kod.
Tabii,
şöyle bir sınıf işte.
Tem,
o orijinali olmasa,
biz de yazardık.
Template type name de,
efendim,
type name,
C eşittir,
studdekin,
T açılımı,
class,
tech,
protected,
c türünden,
C,
public.
Kolay olandan zor olana doğru yazalım arkadaşlar.
Dın dın.
Hangi atribütü kullanacağım?
No discard,
suit size t,
size,
const,
no accept,
söyleyin,
return,
c'nin size'ı,
işte size fonksiyonu,
konteynerin size'ını çağıracak.
Tık tık,
no discard,
arkadaşlar,
even bool,
empty,
const,
no accept,
return,
chain of the,
empty.
Heret,
arkadaşlar,
top,
söyleyin,
heref top,
efendim,
return,
c'nin,
back'i,
son girelik çıkacak ya,
zaten back fonksiyonu da referans döndürdüğü için,
bir problem yok.
Void,
push,
const,
pre,
ref,
while,
c'nin,
neden şimdi konteynerin pushback fonksiyonu olması gerektiğini görüyorsunuz,
c'nin pushback'i,
while,
void,
push,
pre,
ref,
while,
c'nin,
c'nin pushback'i,
tut,
move,
while,
anlamadığınız bir kod var mı arkadaşlar?
Ya da,
Necati,
sen yanlış yazıyorsun,
böyle yazsak daha iyi olur dediğiniz bir kod var mı?
Evet.
İşte bakın push fonksiyonu,
overload ettim arkadaşlar,
move için,
top fonksiyonu,
once overload yapabilirim,
orijinal öyle,
empty fonksiyonu,
size fonksiyonu,
push,
top,
arkadaşlar,
top fonksiyonu,
onu yazdık mı?
Onu da yazalım.
Void,
top,
bakın void fonksiyon,
return,
return değil,
c'nin,
popback fonksiyonu.
İşte diyorum ki,
bunun olması için,
popback'inin,
pushback'inin,
ve arkadaşlar,
back fonksiyonunun,
olması gerekir.
Hatta,
hatta,
bir fonksiyon daha var.
İzleyin.
O da,
constructor grubunu yazmıyorum.
Constructor grubunda,
işte,
arkadaşlar,
şöyle bir constructor var,
stack,
container,
c,
ref,
efendim,
c,
takip edebiliyor muyuz?
Hatta,
hatta,
fonks,
c,
ref,
o,
bayağı güzel,
stack sınıfı yazdık,
değil mi?
efendim,
bir de şöyle koyardım,
c,
ref,
move,
c,
bir de ne yazalım,
arkadaşlar,
bir de,
emplace fonksiyonu yazalım,
template,
bakın,
member template,
çünkü,
perfect bonnet link yapacağız,
pamphlet type name,
arcs,
word,
emplace,
arkadaşlar,
arcs,
ref,
C'nin,
pushback'i,
neyi özellereyim,
C'nin emplace back'i,
step forward,
arcs,
ding ding ding,
işte alın size,
bir,
stack sınıfı,
arkadaşlar,
şimdi,
container adaptörü,
derken,
gayet de güzel gösteriyor,
happy topu,
bir tane aldım,
container,
onun interfezini,
doğrudan vermek yerine,
adapte ettim,
ama sonuçta,
her şeyi yapan,
arka planda benim,
container sınıfım,
değil mi?
aldım bunu da,
notlar dosyasına koydum.
Şimdi birkaç stack örneği yapalım,
arkadaşlar,
include stack,
include iStream,
evet bakın şimdi,
show başlıyor,
include string,
bütün fonksiyonları,
mümkün olduğu kadar,
tek örnekle göstereceğim,
stack'in,
string açılımı,
arkadaşlar,
names,
cout,
size eşittir,
names'in size'ı,
sıfır,
boş,
cout,
all alfa,
is empty,
boş musun,
sen bana boş musun,
evet,
names'in,
empty'si,
şu anda,
default construct dediğimiz,
siteyimiz,
boş,
derleyelim,
evet,
is empty true,
şimdi,
push işlemi yapalım,
utility,
bağışlık dosyamızı,
ekleyelim,
arkadaşlar,
beş kez dönen döngüyle,
string as,
eşittir,
random name,
artı,
random,
surname,
şimdi siteye sokarken yazıyorum,
siyağı,
s,
arkadaşlar,
ne bileyim,
İngilizce bir şeyler yazmak canım,
is being pushed,
biraz kaba gibi,
evet,
bıng bıng bıng bıng,
names,
push,
s,
hatta bakın işte,
arkadaşlar,
yapma dediğim şeyi,
ben yapıyorum,
şu kodu,
kod review da görsem,
hemen çizerdim,
neden,
e çünkü,
artık bu nesneyi kullanmayacağım,
ama böyle yaparsam,
kopyalamaya neden olurum,
şöyle yaparsam,
nasıl o nesneyi,
tekrar o değerini kullanmayacağım,
taşırım,
değil mi,
süper,
şimdi,
döngüden çıktığımızda,
siteimizdeki,
duruma bir bakalım,
Kurtan,
açgöze is being pushed,
Kerim Aybeyaz,
Emine Cengaver,
Bekir Beyaz,
Kenan Kahraman,
size 5 oldu,
is empty true iken,
false döndürdü,
şimdi,
Arkadaşlar,
nedense şimdi,
bu profesyonel tarafta,
C++'da,
şöyle bir eğilim var,
ben her zaman,
uyuduğumu söyleyemem de,
ben de artık,
artık demeyeyim,
çoktandır,
üretimde,
ben de böyle kullanıyorum,
bak şimdi,
normalde,
normalde şöyle bir while döngüsü kullanmak yerine,
while,
değil,
my stack,
empty,
siz de kendi görüşünüzü söyleyin,
olur mu,
my stack değilmiş,
bir name bitmiş,
names,
empty,
aslında yapmak istediğim şu,
see out,
my names,
top,
yani en üsttekine,
eriştim,
onun değerini yazdırdım,
ve,
names,
top,
buraya kadar,
takip edebildiniz mi,
arkadaşlar,
evet,
ve,
döngüden çıktıktan sonra,
konuşacağım,
merak etmeyin,
tekrar,
stack'in boğaç aldığını bir görelim,
evet,
bakın,
eklerken,
çiler,
gamsız,
Necmeddin,
çelik,
canan,
merzipan,
tuğra,
ezer geçer,
helal,
ceylan hep güler,
ama,
stackten çıkartırken,
son giren,
ilk çıktı,
ceylan,
tuğra,
canan,
Necmeddin,
çiler,
gamsız,
en son,
arkadaşlar,
işte,
tipik,
stack bu,
başka ne diyelim,
yalnız,
burada,
az önce şunu söylemek istemiştim,
şöyle bir döngü,
artık biraz çirkin geliyor programcılara,
böyle bir döngü yerine,
yine de for döngüsü kullanmayı tercih ediyorlar,
aslında ben de destekliyorum,
yani,
bu döngüde bir yanlışlık yok,
ya da derleyici daha etkin kod üretiyor falan,
ama onu da değil,
daha kompakt duruyor,
bakın,
o zaman şöyle yazacağım,
izleyin,
for,
birinci ifade yok,
arkadaşlar,
yine aynı şekilde,
names empty,
olmadığı sürece,
üçüncü ifade olarak,
names,
hop,
ben daha çok seviyorum bunu gerçekten,
hatta çoğunlukla,
vlogta,
gerektirmediği için,
arkadaşlar,
evet,
bu kadar,
bilmiyorum,
siz,
en az bir arkadaşım görüş belirsin,
why döngüsü mü,
yazmayı tercih ederdiniz burada,
bu şekilde for döngüsü mü,
muhammet yusuf for,
evet,
var mı başka görüş belirten,
valla herkes for,
helal olsun,
ben de,
bundan sonra,
why,
ben bazen program,
dinleyenler rahatsız oluyor diye,
böyle yazmıyorum,
ama,
Atul Kadir diyor ki,
Atul Kadir ben sizin,
mesajınıza da cevap vermeyi unutmuşum,
lütfen,
dersten sonra,
bana yazın oldu mu,
kusura bakmayın,
evet,
şimdi,
yine aynı şey olduğunu,
görüyoruz,
arkadaşlar,
and place monksiyonu da var tabii ki,
yani örnek,
bir örnek yapalım,
mesela,
bizim,
date,
başlık dosyamızı,
ekleyelim,
date.h,
ve,
stekin,
date,
açılımı,
dates,
burada artık,
tarih mi oluyor,
yoksa,
arkadaşlar,
randevu mu oluyor,
siz karar verin,
ama bizimki tarih gerçekten,
şimdi,
mesela,
10 kez dönen,
ya da 5 kez dönen,
döngüde,
arkadaşlar,
dates'in,
uşu,
yerine,
and place'ini,
çağırıyorum,
argümanları,
perfect forward ediyor,
yani örneğin,
ne diyelim,
arkadaşlar,
i artı 1,
5 olduğuna göre,
efendim,
bu da,
2019,
artı,
i,
oldu umarım,
evet,
ve şimdi,
yine,
for,
normal yazık mı,
dates,
empty,
olmadığı,
sürece,
arkadaşlar,
dates'in,
topu,
ve,
siyah,
dates'in,
topu,
evet,
tabii,
date'in,
insörter olduğu için,
bu,
çalışacak değil mi,
date sınıfını,
evet,
5 Mayıs,
2023,
aslında son,
eklediğim tarih,
4 Nisan,
2022,
3 Mart,
2021,
2 Şubat,
2020,
1 Ocak,
2019,
arkadaşlar,
bu arada bir şey daha söyleyeyim,
bakınız,
şimdi,
izleyin,
top komisyonu,
referans döndürüyor,
yani,
en üsttekine,
sadece eriştirmiyor,
en üsttekini,
manipüle de edebilirsiniz,
mesela örnek,
arkadaşlar,
bakın bakın,
dates'in,
topu,
artı artı,
date sınıfının artı artı,
operatör fonksiyonu vardı,
tarihi bir gün arttırıyordu,
dolayısıyla,
şimdi,
aslında,
tarih,
bir gün artmış oldu,
dates'in,
topu,
arkadaşlar,
yalnız,
c++20 ile,
hadi son sözlerimizi söyleyelim artık,
hayattaki olmasa da,
bu,
stekle ilgili,
bir ekleme daha yapıldı,
ben zaten eleştiriyordum,
niye yok,
arkadaşlar,
şimdi,
default,
konstruktör var,
default konstruktör,
siteyi boş başlatıyor,
efendim,
konteyner parametreli konstruktör var,
o da okey,
tabii ki,
copy konstruktör,
move konstruktör,
onlar var,
fakat,
range konstruktör yoktu,
sonradan range konstruktör da eklendi,
yani,
bakın mesela,
int,
ar,
neden olmasın ki,
niye olmasın ki,
pek hala olmadıydı,
ve oldu,
bence,
iyi de oldu,
bir,
altı,
dört,
izleyin,
site'in,
int açılımı,
my stack,
ya da i stack,
evet,
i stack fotoğraf sitesi miydi,
i stack,
ve,
begin ar,
and ar.
Bakın,
bu,
geçerli değil ki,
yan patlamamıyorsam,
c++ 20 ile,
bu konstruktör eklendi,
iyi de oldu,
çok da ihtiyaç var aslında buna,
yani,
bakınız şimdi,
bu sırayla,
s'ye,
eklenmiş olacak,
yani,
aslında,
bu sefer şöyle yazayım,
ha peki,
yapalım böyle yazalım,
for,
ya da,
bundan sonraki dersleri de kullanmak üzere,
bir fonksiyonu yazalım,
arkadaşlar,
evet,
template type name t,
void,
print pop,
stoot,
arkadaşlar,
staking,
hey açılımı,
ya da,
arkadaşlar,
bakın şimdi,
konseptlerin de ne kadar gerekli bir eleman olduğunu görüyorsunuz,
şimdi,
pembring pop fonksiyonunu yazacağım,
eğer şöyle yazarsam,
stack,
tut stack,
efendim,
ref,
p,
sadece,
stack specializationları için çalışır,
o mesela,
q için çalışmaz,
çünkü parametresi,
sadece stack istiyor,
eğer şöyle yaparsam,
arkadaşlar,
o,
bu fonksiyona,
bütün nesneleri gönderebilirim,
syntax hatası olursa,
buradaki koddan dolayı olur,
ama bu fonksiyon çağrıldı diye bir syntax hatası olmaz,
takip edebiliyor muyuz,
ama şimdi,
şunu nasıl yapacağım mesela,
düşünsenize,
ben,
öyle bir print pop fonksiyonu istiyorum ki,
örneğin,
arkadaşlar,
stack içinde,
q içinde çalışsın,
örnek,
burada işte,
ya,
geleneksel,
eski,
maalesef,
işte,
iç açı olmayan teknikleri kullanacağım,
ya da,
konseptleri,
tabi,
C++ 20 ve sonrası için,
konseptleri iyi öğreneceksiniz,
bir template'i,
nasıl,
constraint edebilirsiniz,
onu öğreneceksiniz,
ama biz şimdilik,
const,
stack'in,
t açılımı,
ref yapalım,
ve,
döngüyü buraya taşıyalım,
her defasında kodu yazmayalım,
bir,
s,
empty,
kop,
ama arkadaşlar,
bu,
const olamaz,
const olursa,
syntaxe taslı olur,
zaten,
o yüzden ismi print pop,
çünkü,
stay sonuçta boşalacak,
mütehit ediyor,
değil mi,
associate,
s,
top,
da,
and,
sure,
than,
or Ctrl,
but,
oh,
you,
how we can,
okay,
you,
.
Evet, şimdi bakalım her devasla yazmak zorunda kalmayacağım, printbub.
4619725 neden? Çünkü şu sırayla push ediyor değil mi?
İstekten çıkartırken son giden ilk çıktığı için ters sırada aldım. Takip edebildik mi?
Evet, böyle bir konstruktörümüz var. Range konstruktörümüzün olması da büyük bir avantaj.
Efendim hemen mülakatların programcılarla yapılan, her seviyede programcılarla yapılan mülakatların tipik algoritma sorusunda soralım.
Ödev olarak herkes kendi yapsın. Arkadaşlar şimdi sitenin kullanıldığı senaryolardan iki tanesini zaten herkes biliyordur arkadaşlar.
Birincisi, recursive algoritmaları recursive olmaktan çıkartıp iteratif hale getirmek için çoğunlukla stack veri yapısını kullanıyoruz.
Yani recursivity'den iteratif'e geçtiğimizde bir stack ihtiyacı doğuyor.
Ama en tipik siteyi anlatan problem arkadaşlar parantez matching algoritması.
Hadi bakalım şimdi öyle bir yazı geliyor ki boolean is match const.string.rev.s.
Arkadaşlar bu fonksiyon boolean döndürecek.
İzleyin.
Ulin noduna çekiyorum formatlamayı.
Parantezler. Parantez derken bunlar kabul ediliyor.
Parantez, köşeli parantez, yani İngilizcesinde parantezsiz, square bracket, angular bracket ve brace.
Parantezler uygun şekilde tapanıyor ama.
Yani örneğin arkadaşlar aç parantez, aç parantez, köşeli parantez A çarpı, bu tabi bir C ifadesi falan değil, matematiksel bir ifade de olabilir.
Evet parantezi kapattım.
Küme parantezi, küme parantezi X artı Y artı Z küme parantezlerini kapattım.
Arkadaşlar şu en dıştaki parantezi kapattım.
Hatta artı açısal parantez içinde, şuraya bir de açısal parantez koyalım.
Kastırı da uzatmayalım.
Evet.
Mesela şu anda parantezler match.
Parantez match olmaktan neyi kastettiğimi açıklamama gerek var mı?
Ben bunu C'de de ödev olarak veriyorum.
Ve bu fonksiyonu yazarken tabi stack kullanmanız isteniyor.
Arkadaşlar stack ile alakasını biliyorsunuz değil mi?
Algoritma son derece basit.
Şimdi bir açılan grubu var.
Açılanlar opening parantezsiz ya da left parantezsiz, left angular bracket, left square bracket ve left brace ya da opening brace.
Bir de bunların kapananları var.
Algoritmayı herkes biliyor mu?
Açıklamama gerek var mı?
Açıklayayım mı açıklamayayım mı?
Arkadaşlar yazıyı dolaşıyorsunuz.
Açılan gördüğünüzde siteye push ediyorsunuz.
Push open parantezsiz, opening parantezsiz.
Yukarıdaki yazıyı, şunları sileyim.
Evet.
Push, push, push.
Parantez grubu olmayanları geçtim.
A'yı geçtim.
Kapananla karşılaştığımda
Parantez matching diye geçiyor.
Ben hep öyle görüyorum.
Oğuzhan Bey.
Kapananla karşılaştığınızda
bu durumda
siteyin top'ında onun açılanı olması gerekiyor.
Bakın kapanan geldi.
Şu anda
siteyin top'ındaki
onun açılanı mı?
Ona karşılık gelen açılan mı?
Yani closing'e karşılık gelen opening mi?
Yes.
O zaman eğer no ise
yani bu noktada
eğer siteyin top'ında
closing
square bracket
geldiğinde
siteyin top'ında
opening square bracket olmasaydı
hemen false dönecektik.
Devam etmeye gerek yok.
Eğer açılanı varsa
hop.
Şimdi çarpıyı geçtim.
Açılan köşeli parantez push.
B'yi geçtim.
Hop.
Arkadaşlar
evet.
Parantez
takip edebiliyor muyuz?
Şurada kalmıştık.
Evet.
Efendim
şimdi
burada
açısal parantez gitmiş.
Onu da koyalım.
Evet.
Parantez
işte bir
algoritmayı gördünüz.
Sonuçta
sonuna kadar gitmeme gerek yok.
Yalnız tabi burada
niye dikkat etmeniz gerekiyor?
A.
bir closing ile
karşılaştığınızda
siteyin top'ındaki bunun
opening'i değilse
return false.
Bir de
önemli bir şart daha var.
Yazıyı
dolaştınız.
Yazı bitti.
Ne olması
gerekir?
Cevap
siteyin
boş
olması
gerekir.
Yazı bittiğinde
stack boş
değilse
o zaman yine
false
dönüyorsunuz.
Mülakatlarda
falan sorular
çok tipik bir soru olduğu için
stackle
de ilgisi olduğu için
bir sorayım
dedim.
İşte değerli
arkadaşlarım
bu stack
son girenin
last in
earth
ad.
Gerçek hayatta da
stack
mesela
şirketlerin
mağazları uyguluyor değil mi?
İşten çıkarma
gerektiğinde
işe son girenleri
çıkartıyorlar.
Gerçi tersini
yapan da var
kıdem tazminatı
vesaire nedeniyle
ama tipik olarak
son girenler çıkıyor.
Eskiler
kalıyor.
Mesela orada
stack sistemi var.
Stacklerimi de
aslında İngilizce'de
şöyle de kullanıyor değil mi?
Doğal
oradan geliyor zaten
stacklerimi.
Mesela
üst üste
tabaklardan
ya da kitaplardan
bahsederken
a stack of
books
ya da
a stack of
plates
falan gibi
ifadeler
kullanılıyor.
Çünkü
tabağa
koyarken
yeni tabağa
üste
koyuyorum
ama biri
benden
tabak
istediğinde
en üsttekini
alıp
veriyorum.
Ama
Q
böyle değil.
da
işte
meşhur
sinema
kuyruğu.
En çok
kullanılan
veri yapılarından
abstract
data taklarda
bir
stackse
biri
kuyruk.
Hatta bence
kuyucuk
stackten
daha çok
kullanılıyor.
İlk gireneği
çıkar.
Bilet
alacağız
arkadaşlar.
Efendim
Rolling
Stones
gelmiş
yıllar öncesinde
ve
kuyruğa
giriyoruz.
Cengiz Han
kuyruğun başında
Deniz
daha sonra
Emir
ondan sonra
Mert
Muhammed
daha sonra
ama
bilet
satmaya
başladıkları
zaman
ilk giren
Deniz
bilet alıyor.
O aldıktan sonra
Emir oluyor.
Sonra
Mert
alıyor.
İlk giren
ilk
çıkar.
Arkadaşlar
bazı
borsa
işlemlerinde
birden fazla
emir söz
konusu olduğu
zaman
belirli
ülkelerin
borsalarında
algoritmik
trading
tarafta olanlar
varsa belki
biliyorlardır.
Emirlerin
kuyruk
sistemiyle
kapatılması
mecburiyeti
var bazı
yerlerde
bazı
borsa
işlemlerinde.
Yani
4 tane
5 tane
pozisyon
açıyorsanız
o zaman
ilk açtığınız
pozisyonu
kapatmadan
ikinci açtığınız
pozisyonu
örneğin
kapatamayabiliyorsunuz
bazı
finansal
işlemlerde
böyle bir
zorunluluk da var.
Şimdi
bizim bir tane
başlık dosyamız
var.
Bu sefer
başlık dosyamız
Q
ama
hem
priority
Q
hem de
burada
yani
priority
Q ile
Q için
ayrı
neler yok
header'lar
yok.
Arkadaşlar
bunun
interfesi
birbirine
çok benziyor.
Stack ile
neredeyse
aynı.
Sadece
farklılık
şurada
Türkçe'de
bazen
kullanılıyor.
Şimdi
ben de
AKP
propagandası
yapayım.
Tüp gaz
kuyrukları
vardı
benim zamanımda.
Şimdi
tüp gaz
yok zaten
neredeyse
silinde
kuyruk da yok.
İşte
arkadaşlar
tüp gaz
kuyruğuna
girilirdi.
Yok
artık
utanacağım
söylemiyorum.
Ve
bir
kuyruk
başı
olmuş
bir de
kuyruk
sonu
olmuş.
Kuyruk
başındaki
o sefer
hani
kuyruğunun
üstteki
falan
diyemiyorum.
Kuyruk
başı
diyorum ben
ona.
Kuyruk
başı
ilk
olacak.
Hizmet
verildiğinde
kuyruk
sonunda
maalesef
ona sıra
gelirse
o da
son
hizmet
alacak.
Burada
şaka
bir yana
top
fonksiyonu
yerine
kuyruk
başına ve
sonuna
erişmek
için
front
ve
back
fonksiyonları
var.
Onun dışında
abstract
data type'ın
farklı
interfejsi
yok.
Arkadaşlar
sadece
yapı
farklı.
Burada
ilk
giren
değil de
son
giren
ilk
çıkıyor.
Ve
burada
son
giren
değil de
ilk
giren
çıkıyor.
burada
yine
adapte edilecek
interfejde
konteyner
yine
template
parametresi
ve yine
dek.
Yani
gerek
stack'te
vektörde
default
template
argümanı
dek.
Ama
priority
queue
için
dek zaten
mümkün
değil.
Priority
queue
da ise
biliyorsunuz
heap
veri yapısı
olduğu için
vektörel
bir veri
yapısı
gerekiyor.
Orada
kısıtlamalar
daha fazla.
vektörel
veri yapısı
olarak
priority
queue
da
stutt
vektör
default
template
argümanı.
Efendim
queue
nun
int
açılımı
arkadaşlar
evet
ne diyelim
queue
diyelim.
çok olunca
kod da komik oluyor.
Arkadaşlar
yine
default
constructor
container
parametreli
constructor
daha sonradan
eklenen
C++
ile eklenen
range
constructor
var.
Fakat
interfacede
bakın bakın
arkadaşlar
yine
protected
data
member
kalıtım
yoluyla
kullanılabilmesi
için C
ama burada
görüyorsunuz
back
fonksiyonu
var.
Arkadaşlar
front
fonksiyonu
var.
Front
fonksiyonu
kuruldaki
ilk
öğe'ye
erişmek
için
referanse
maddiyle
back
son öğe'ye
erişmek
için
yine
push
ve pop
fonksiyonu
var.
Sadece
top yerine
back
ve
front
fonksiyonu
var.
Yine
gather
larımızdan
empty
ve size
var.
Push
karşılığı
perfect
boarding
için
mps
fonksiyonu
var.
Size
swap
fonksiyonu
var.
İşte
bu
kadar.
Arkadaşlar
yani
sonuçta
yine
örneğin
şöyle bir
döngü
oluşturalım.
Arkadaşlar
döngüde
kuru
push
yapalım.
i
çarpı
iki
artı
bir
ve
yine
tabii ki
depot
konstrakt edilmiş
kuyruğumuz
boş
ama en azından
çıktıktan sonra
döngüden
bu sefer
biraz daha kısa
gideceğim
ve ara
vereceğim.
q'nun
ice
fonksiyonunu
çağırıyorum.
empty
fonksiyonu
alt
dönüyor.
Onu
çağırmıyorum.
Evet
on
ve
yine
for
hatta
yok
for
olmasın
mesela
şöyle
olsun
see out
arkadaşlar
kuyruk
başı
kürtçe oldu
ama
efendim
q nokta
front
ilk giren
necati oldu
olacak
şunu
iyi yap
bizi
takip etme
zorluğuna
sokma
buyruk
sonu
back
yine
aynı
şekilde
for
değil
q
empty
arkadaşlar
q
nokta
up
ve
q
nokta
tap
diyorum
q
nokta
front
tabi
bu
işlemden
sonra
kuyruğumuz
da
boşalmış
oldu
saat
21.01
ara
veriyoruz
21.20
de
devam
edeceğiz
arkadaşlar
evet
işte
q
da
öyle
ilk girenin
ilk çıktığı
veri yapısı
interfej birbirine
çok benziyor
dedik
sadece
front ve
back
fonksiyonları
var
top
fonksiyonu
yerine
ve gelelim
3.
container
adapter
imize
ingilizce de
bunlara
container
adapter
deniyor
arkadaşlar
üç
sınıfa
efendim
bunun dışında
bu konu
bittikten sonra
birazdan
böyle
container
ı
başka
sınıflarımızda
var
onları
göreceğiz
bunlardan bir tanesi
tuple
container
değil
ama
pair'in
çoklusu
pair
iki tane
böyli
birbirine
bağlıyor
bir arada
tutuyor
fakat
tuple
da
böyle bir
sınır yok
zaten
pair'in
kendisi de
aynı zamanda
bir
tuple
ikiyle
sınırlı
olmayacak
şekilde
n tane
öy'yi
birbirine
bağlıyor
türkçe
benim hoşuma
gitmese de
demet
sözcüğünü
kullananlar
var
ya da
bağ
sözcüğünü
kullananlar
var
priorite
q'ya
birazdan
değineceğim
ondan sonra
tuple
göreceğiz
yine
bir de
bitset
sınıfımız var
adı üstünde
bir bitvektör
interfejisine
sahip
aynı zamanda
operatör overloadingden
de faydalanan
bitset
sınıfı
bunlar
tamamlandıktan
sonra
şöyle birkaç
derslik
ne yapalım
bir ders planı
verelim
arkadaşlar
bazı
algoritmalarımız var
değinmediğimiz
o algoritmalara
değineceğiz
ama arada
yine
önemli bir
alt başlığımız
daha var
functional
başlık
dosyasındaki
adaptörler
ve
yardımcı
öğeler
burada
stutbind
memfn
notfn
gibi
adaptörlerimiz
var
aynı zamanda
arkadaşlar
stutfunction
isimli
önemli bir
function
wrapper
sınıfımız var
yine
reference
wrapper
sınıfı
da
functional
başlık
dosyasındaki
öğeler
arasında
yani ilk
2-3
dersimizde
tuple
bitset
belirli
algoritmalar
functional
başlık
dosyasındaki
öğeler
ve küçük
küçük
şimdi saymayayım
yine
alt başlıklarımız
olacak
hemen
priority
q
başlık
dosyası
yine
q
öncelik
kuyruğu
bildiğiniz gibi
heap
veri yapısını
kullanıyor
burada
arkadaşlar
iki tane terim var
biliyorsunuz
biri
max heap
ben
burada
max priority
q
diyeceğim
ikincisi
min heap
max heap
de
siz
ya da
max priority
q
önceliği
en yüksek
olan
en büyük
yani
kuyruktan
çıkarttığınız zaman
en büyük
değeri
çıkartıyorsunuz
bir karşılaştırma
ilişkisine
göre
fakat
min q
da
minimum
priority q
da
bu sefer
tam tersi
arkadaşlar
önceliği
en yüksek
olan
en küçük
priority q
her dilde
aynı mı
tuple
hayır
arkadaşlar
mesela
python'daki
kavramsal olarak
aynı
mert gör
ama
tabii ki
interfej
aynı değil
bizdeki
tuple
tamamen
jenerik programlama
tarafına
uygun
bir sınıf
diyelim
şablon
peki
şimdi
priority q
hemen
interfejisini
görelim
arkadaşlar
bakın
burada
iki yerine
üç tane
template
parametresi
var
şimdi
birinci
template
parametresi
priority q
da tutulan
üyenin
türü
yani
int tutacaksınız
kuyrukta
int
string
tutacaksınız
ikinci
template
parametresi
edinilecek
container'ın
member olarak
alınacak
container'ın
türü
diğer ikisinde
default template
argümanı
arkadaşlar
stud
deck
idi
oysa
burada
stud
vector
vektör
container'ı
burada
contiguous
olduğu için
seçenem
default
template
argümanı
zaten
diğer
ikisi
doğrudan
uygun
değil
arkadaşlar
list
örneğin
uygun
değil
ama
üçüncü
bir template
parametresi
daha var
eğer
max q
istiyorsanız
default
template
argümanı
olarak
list
kullanacaksınız
burada
üçüncü
template
parametresi
arkadaşlar
karşılaştırma
işlemlerini
yapacak
efendim
kolubunun
türü
default
olarak
list
container'ın
value
type'ı
açılımını
alıyor
yani örneğin
container'ınız
vektörün
int
açılımıysa
üçüncü
template
parametresine
karşılık
gelen
default
template
argümanı
list
in
açılımı
arkadaşlar
yine
efendim
interfazimizdeki
fonksiyonlar
neredeyse
aynı
fakat
burada
az önce
söylediğim gibi
a
vektör
kullanmaya
engel
bir durumunuz
yoksa
b
l'si
kullanmaya
engel
bir durumunuz
yoksa
doğrudan
priority
q'nun
int
açılımını
diğer
template
argümanlarını
default
template
argümanı
seçebilirsiniz
örneğin
priority
q'nun
int
açılımı
diyelim ki
arkadaşlar
max
q
terminolojik olarak
buna
max q
dendiği için
ben de
max q
ismini verdim
hemen
arkadaşlar
tabi şunu
yine söyleyeyim
default
constructor
var
range
constructor
var
container
parametreli
constructor
var
aradaki bir parka
göstermek istiyorum
bakınız
şimdi
diyelim ki
ben
buraya
bazı
öğeleri
ekleyeceğim
arkadaşlar
şöyle yapalım
bir
iRand
nesnesi
oluşturalım
bu standart
değil
benim kütüvanemde
myRand
ve
10 kez dönen
bir döngüyle
önce
sokarken
kuyruğa
değerlerini
bir değişkende
tutalım
auto
while
eşittir
yine
9.99
arasında
değerler
üretsin
myRand
seeout
while
arkadaşlar
maxq
push
while
push yine
iki tane
overloadu var
açıklamaya
gerek yok
buraya
kadar
bir
derleyelim
bir bak
edelim
şu sırayla
container'a
öncelik
kuyruğuna
sokuyorum
arkada
arkadaşlar
heap veri
yapısı
olduğunu
hatırlayın
onlara
anlatmıştım
heap
algoritmalarında
ama şimdi
örneğin
buradan
top işlemi
yapsam
ya da
top işlemini
yapsam
en büyük olan
öğe
986'yı
çıkartacağım
evet
ama
şimdi onu da
gösterelim
yine
şunları
söylemeye
gerek var mı
bilmiyorum
ama
yazalım
madem
zarar yok
size
eşittir
hepsinde
ortak
zaten
max
q
arkadaşlar
size
mp
fonksiyonu
onu
çağırmayayım
bu sefer
evet
or
değil
max
q
empty
max
q
up
ve
or döngüsünün
gövdesinde
body'sinde
max
q
arkadaşlar
curve
arkadaşlar
burada
hemen şunu da
söyleyelim
çok güzel bir çalışma
bu konteynerları
sizde
bu
konteyner adaptörlerini
sizde en az bir kere
implemente edin
özellikle
prior
fq'da
ne yapacaksınız
interfazdeki fonksiyonları
implemente ederken
heap
algoritmalarını
kullanacaksınız
yani
make heap
sort heap
hop heap
ve
push heap
arkadaşlar
fonksiyonları
yani
priority
q
jenerik
olarak
implemente edilsin
çok güzel bir çalışma
evet
jenerik
olarak
efendim
ve
kuyruktan
çıktıktan sonra
hepsi
size
sıfır olacak
şimdi bakalım
en büyük görüyorsunuz
şimdi
iki taneymiş
tabi ki burada
eğer bu bir sınıf olsaydı
küçük tür operatörü
kullanılacaktı
değil mi
yani
şimdi
kodu biraz değiştirelim
priority q
iki tane değişiklik yapalım
birinci değişiklik
template argümanını
less yerine
greater yapalım
yalnız burada o
üçüncü template
parametresi olduğu için
arkadaşlar
evet
ben
şöyle bir
type tip ismi
kullanayım
using
izleyin
template type name
t
using
g
gpq
isme bakın
evet
eşittir
stut
priority q'nun
t virgül
stut
vektörün
t virgül
arkadaşlar
stut
greater'ın
evet
ne açıldığımı
arkadaşlar
ya da yazmayalım
greater'ın t
açılımı
diyelim biz
sonuçta
bu bizim
türeş
ismimiz
ve
şöyle yazalım
gpq
int
int açılımı
min q
yine push
işlemini
yapıyorum
yine min q'nun
size
fonksiyonunu
çağırıyorum
ve
burada da
uzatmayalım
max q
yerine
isim değişikliği
min q
dedim
bu sefer
en küçük
en baştan
çıkacak
tabu örneğin
date
sınıfı
olsaydı
son olarak
onu örnek
olarak
verelim
hepsini
silelim
bakın
şimdi
priority q'nun
date
açılımı
x
10 kez
dönen bir
döngü
x
m
place
i
rent
day
virgü
a
ya da
random date
vardı zaten
x'in
push'u
date'in
random'ı
ama şimdi
for
değil
x
empty
pop
see out
x
up
bu
priority q'nun
date virgül
vektörün
arkadaşlar
l's'in
date
açılımı
oldu
yani yine
max q
oldu
ve
derleyip
çalıştıralım
tarihler
gördüğünüz gibi
büyükten
küçüğe
şimdi değiştirelim
priority q'nun
date virgül
vektörün
date
virgül
vektörün
date virgül
arkadaşlar
greater
date
açılımı
şimdi de
tarihler
küçükten
büyüğe
doğru
gelecek
anlaştık mı
arkadaşlar
sizin bir sorunuz
yoksa
priority q'yu
da geçiyorum
çünkü daha önce
heap
data structure'dan
bahsetmiştik
stl'deki
heap
algoritmalarından
bahsetmiştik
şimdi
bizim biraz daha fazla
zamanımızı
alacak
topulu
bir
öğrenelim
arkadaşlar
değer'in genel
mantığını
biliyorsunuz
iki
iki tane
öğeyi
belirli işlemleri
gerçekleştirmek için
bir arada
tutuyorum
örneğin
fonksiyona
parametre olarak
geçmek için
fonksiyondan
geri dönüş
değeri olarak
almak için
sınıfa
bir veri
elemanı
yapmak için
pekala
aslında bunun için
bir sınıf da
kullanabilirim
fakat
eğer kullandığımda
aslında
vurgulanan
bunların
arasında
böyle
ortak bir
interfezi
gerektirecek
kadar yakın
bir ilişki
yok
önemli olan
bunları
bir bağlamda
bir kontekste
bir bandı
olarak
birlikte
tutmak
peyr bir sınıf
şablonu
peyr'i anlatmayacağım
zaten biliyorsunuz
fakat
tuple
onun
çoklusu
yani
peyr'in
çoklusu
tuple
bu arada
şöyle
okyanları
eleştiriyorlar
bazen
native speaker'lar
buna
tuple
diyor
değil
tuple
yani
gerçekten
telaffuzu
tuple
yabancılarla
eleştiriyor
evet
arkadaşlar
tuple
başlık dosyasında
yani
kendi
generic
sınıfımız
için
bir
başlık
dosyamız
var
tuple
bir
sınıf
şablonu
ama
variyedik
parametre
paketine
sahip
template
parametre
paketine
sahip
dolayısıyla
örneğin
böyle bir
sınıf
kullanabilirim
yani
parametre paketinde
hiç
tür
argümanı
olmayabilir
bir tane
tür
argümanı
olabilir
peyr gibi
iki tane
tür
argümanı
olabilir
üç tane
dört tane
en tane
tür
argümanı
olabilir
tıkkı
peyr'de
olduğu gibi
bir
fonksiyonun
parametresi
bir
tuple
türünden
olabilir
bir
fonksiyonun
iki
tane
üç
dört
tane
beş
en
tane
değer
döndürmesi
için
fonksiyonun
geri dönüş
değeri
türü
toplu
olabilir
sınıfınızın
variyedik
olarak mı
kullanılır
genelde
diyor
Yiğit
soruyu
belki
tamamlamamış
olabilirim
bu
variyedik
sınıf
şablonu
zaten
yani
başka
şekilde
kullanma
imkanı
yok
yani
bu
bir
sınıf
şablonu
variyedik
parametre
paketine
sahip
dolayısıyla
siz
tupple
kullanmak
istediğiniz
zaman
kadar
türü
üyesi
verebilirsiniz
örneğin
tupple'ın
arkadaşlar
int virgül
double virgül
efendim
stud string
virgül
date
specialization
tabi
ilgili
başlık
dosyaları
dahil
edilmiş
olarak
bu bir
sınıf
Yiğit
mesela bu
olmasaydı
bu başka
bir sınıf
olacaktı
bu olmasaydı
bu başka
bir sınıf
olacaktı
anlaşıldı
mı
evet
şurada
kalmıştık
bu
fonksiyonun
parametre
değişkeninin
türü
topulu
olabilir
fonksiyonun
geri dönüş
değeri
türü
topulu
olabilir
sınıfın
bir ya da
birden fazla
data member
statik
ya da
non-statik
topulu
olabilir
konteynerlarda
topul
böyeleri
tutabilirim
arkadaşlar
şimdi
verin
genel mantığını
biliyorsak
topula
biraz daha
iyi yaklaşabiliriz
ama
topul
tabi
variatik
parametre
paketine
sahip olduğu için
biraz daha
karmaşık
arkadaşlar
müperdeki
genel mantığı
burada
anlamamız gerekiyor
bir
topul'ın
herhangi bir
specialization'ı
türünden
bir nesneyi
default
construct
ettiğinizde
örneğin
default
initialize
ettiğinizde
ya da
value
initialize
ettiğinizde
öeler
sıfır
bunu
henüz
görmediğimiz
stud variant'la
karıştırmayalım
arkadaşlar
bir de
ileride
öğreneceğimiz
stud variant
var
tag union
yani örneğin
bu
tuple değil de
variant'ın
int
double
long
açılımı
olsaydı
union
arka planda
yani ya int
tutacak
ya double
ya long
tutacak
bu değerlerden
birini tutuyor
ama tuple
böyle değil
tuple
üç değeri
birden
tutuyor
yani
böyle bir
tuple
nesnesi
int de tutuyor
double de tutuyor
long de tutuyor
eğer
pair olsaydı
biz
pair'in tuttuğu
öğelere
pair'in
first'ü
ve
second'ı
yani
isimlendirilmiş
data member'larıyla
erişiyorduk
oysa
tuple'da
öğelere
erişmek için
arkadaşlar
get
fonksiyonlarından
birini
çağıracağız
ya
efendim
non-type
template
parametreli
get
fonksiyonu
ya da
type
parametreli
get
fonksiyonu
hepsini
göreceğiz
o zaman önce
buradan
başlayalım
default
construct edilmiş
bir
tuple
nesnesi
arkadaşlar
value
initialize
edilmiş
öğeler
tutuyor
bu
öğelere
erişmek
için
iki tane
olanağımız
var
ikisi de
birer
fonksiyon
şablonu
olan
get
yalnız
iki tane
ayrı
get
fonksiyon
şablonu
var
birinde
template
type
parametresi
var
hangi
türden
öğeye
erişmek
istiyorsanız
onu
kullanacaksınız
diğerinde
ise
arkadaşlar
non-type
parametre
tuple'daki
indeksi
kullanacaksınız
indeks
yine
tahmin
edebileceğiniz
gibi
zero
base
yani
örneğin
tuple'daki
ilk öğeye
erişmek
için
get
fonksiyonuna
sıfır
indeksini
verip
arkadaşlar
tuple
nesnesini
argüman
olarak
gönderiyorum
hatta
iostream
başlık
dosyasında
dahil
edelim
ve
tuple'daki
öğelerimizden
üçüncüsü
string
olsun
ve
dördüncüsü
de
date
olsun
takip etmeye
çalışın
şimdi bütün öğelerin
değerini
yazdırayım
arkadaşlar
bu int olduğu için
value initialize
edildiğinde
sıfır değeriyle
hayatına
başlamış olacak
aynı şey
double türden
arkadaşlar
öğe için
geçerli
efendim
string için
default
construct edilmiş
olacak
orada
borç yazı
olduğu için
onun
length fonksiyonuna
çağrı yapalım
bakın
tabi
arkadaşlar
referans
döndürdüğünü
söylemeliyiz
ve son olarak
get'i
non-type
template argümanı ile
çağıralım
ve
arkadaşlar
tarihi
yazdıralım
bizim
date sınıfımızın
default
constructörü
date'i
1-1
yapıyordu
idi
derleyelim
burada acele
etmeyeceğim
müsaadenizle
yavaş yavaş
anlatacağım
çünkü bence
çok önemli
bir sınıf
jenerik
programlama
tarafında
biraz sabırlı
olmanızı
istiyorum
gördünüz
değil mi
arkadaşlar
yine
perde olduğu
gibi
parametreli
constructor da var
örneğin
buraya dikkat
şunlar
kalsın
aşağıdaki
bu sefer
length'i
siliyorum
ve
constructor'a
argümanları
geçiyorum
int için
efendim
klasik değerimiz
evet
double için
2.35
string için
Ömer
Paruk
ve
date için
arkadaşlar
date
ve
şimdi
derleyip
çalıştırıyorum
görüyorsunuz
2.35
Ömer
Paruk
2 Mayıs
Cumartesi
eğer bir
ambigüity
olmayacaksa
get
fonksiyonunun
type
parametreli
olanını
kullanabilirsiniz
örneğin
get'in
int
specialization'ı
get'in
arkadaşlar
double
specialization'ı
get'in
string
specialization'ı
ve
get'in
date
specialization'ı
yavaş yavaş
gidiyoruz
işte
sevgili
arkadaşlar
tabi ki
dikkat
sitattan da
sonuna kadar
faydalanıyor
örneğin
3.
parametreyi
bir string
yapsaydım
ki henüz
anlatmadım
literal operator
functions
ve
pamphlet
argümanlarını
explicit
olarak
yazmasaydım
derleyici
constractor'a gönderilen
argümanlardan
tuple'ın
int virgül
double virgül
suit string virgül
date açılımı
olduğunu
oda bakarak
örneğin
constractor'a gönderilen
argümanlardan
çıkarımını
didaktionunu
yapacaktı
gördüğünüz
gibi
takip edebiliyor muyuz
evet
arkadaşlar
sitat olmadan
önce
böyle durumlarda
bizim
yardımcı
fabrika
fonksiyonumuz
kullanılabilir
daha önünde
ben hemen
önce
niyetin
sorusuna
cevap vereyim
birden fazla
olsaydı
mb
güit olacaktı
arkadaşlar bir şeye
dikkat
bakınız
şimdi
tuple x
5.6
long
bu
tuple'ın
hangi
specialization'ı
cevap
tuple'ın
int virgül
double virgül
long virgül
int
specialization'ı
şimdi burada
sorun yok
yet
x
problem yok
arkadaşlar
ister
ilk ölü olan
int'e
erişin
ister
son ölü olan
int'e
erişin
burada dikkat
arkadaşlar
eğer
indeks
geçersizse
bu
compile time'da
test ediliyor
çünkü
bu
zaten
compile time
sabiti
mesela
yiğit
get
deseydim
run time'a ilişkin
bir hata mı
olacaktı
compile time'a ilişkin
bir hata mı
olacaktı
cevap
compile time'a ilişkin
bir hata
olacaktı
derleme zamanında
ya da
benzer şekilde
bakın
yetin
tar
specialization'ı
diyorum
arkadaşlar
gördüğünüz gibi
compile time'da
hata oluyor
anlaşıldı değil mi
yani
olmayan bir
indeks
geçerli olmayan bir
ya da
geçerli olmayan
bir
tür
verdiğinizde
bu
compile time'da
test ediliyor
ama
e
yetin
sorusuna
geri dönelim
eğer ben
şimdi
getin
double
specialization
deseydim
bir tane
double olduğu için
problem olmayacaktı
ama
getin
int
specialization
dediğimde
iki tane
int olduğu için
derleyecek
ambiguity
hatası
verecekti
bu durumda
bunu elde etme
şansım
yok ama
yanlış anlaşamazsın
double'da
aynı türden
iki tane
template argümanı
olabilir
onda
herhangi bir
şekle bir
engel
yok
arkadaşlar
şimdi
aynı durum
variant'ta da
söz konusu
olacak
şöyle
idiomatik
yapılar var
örneğin
couple'dun
bu
türleri
yani
template
argümanları
sizin
problem
domeninizdeki
varlıklara
karşılık
geliyorsa
türeş isim
bildirimi
kullanabilirsiniz
mesela
bakınız
using
diyelim ki
aslında
ben
topal'ın
ilk
üresini
arkadaşlar
kişinin
id'si
olarak
kullanacağım
efendim
id'yi
bir türeş
ismi
yapıyorum
diyelim ki
o int olsun
efendim
bu
diyelim ki
bir tür
ne olsun
register
date
ya da
şöyle
diyelim
enrollment
date
daha
zuhun oldu
ama
date
ve
belki
isim
bakın
using
name
eşittir
to
string
takip edin
şimdi
doğrudan
to
tuple
arkadaşlar
id
efendim
enrollment
date
ya da
id
name
enrollment
date
specialization
hatta buna da
türeş
ismi de verebilirim
using
student
eşittir
tople'ın
id
name
enrollment
date
specialization
aslında bu
tople'ın
int virgül
string virgül
date
açılımı
değil mi
şimdi artık
şöyle kullanma
çantına sahibim
student
s
arkadaşlar
efendim
id
si
ismi
Fatih
çağlayan
ve
enrollment
date
arkadaşlar
yine burada
get
fonksiyonlarını
çağırırken
daha okunaklı
olsun diye
get'in
id
açılımı
sözde
diyebilirim ama
tabi id
demek sonuçta
int demek
get
id
s
iostream
başlık
dosyası
olsan
hocam
struct ile
kullanmaya
göre
bunun
avantajı
nedir
arkadaşlar
şimdi
bu sorunun
net bir cevabı
yok
yani bir
avantaj
olması
gerekmiyor
yani
bazı durumlarda
gerçekten
doğrudan
bir
structure
kullanabilirsiniz
sonuçta
structure
kullandığınız zaman
üyeleri
public
yapacaksınız
isimle
erişeceksiniz
farklı
avantajları
dezavantajları
var ama
tabi
jenerik tarafta
tuplu'nun çok
önemli
avantajları
var
hatta
bazı
teknikler
şimdi
ilerleyen
dakikalarda
göstereceğim
daha konunun
çok başındayız
olsam
tamamen
tuplu
jenerik
olarak
kullanıyor
biraz daha
işin içine
girdiğimizde
aslında
sorunuzun cevabını
da
doğal olarak
örneklerden
anlamış
olacaksınız
şimdi
biraz önce
ilerleyelim
get
id
efendim
name
kodlarda
çok sık
karşımıza
çıkacak
arkadaşlar
idiomatik
yapılardan da
bahsediyorum
get
efendim
enrollment
date
s
bu bir
iki
bazen de
inum
aynı amaçla
kullanıyor
bakın şimdi
şöyle de
olabilirdi
ya da
ikisi beraber
olurdu
inum
arkadaşlar
id
idx
name
efendim
enrollment
idx
kısa kesiyorum
e şimdi bunlar
arkadaşlar
inum
diyelim ki
isim vermek zorunda
da diyelim
idx
hatta
outside
underline
type
outside
ind
seçtim
şimdi artık
gette de
bu sefer
indeksle
yarışırken
biraz daha
kodun
kolay okulmasını
sağlamak için
örneğin
şöyle
yazabilirim
takip edebiliyor muyuz
evet
peki
devam
şimdi
o zaman
toplumumuzda
default
construct
edebiliyorum
parametreli
constructörüm
var
arkadaşlar
neden
faydalanabiliyorum
get
interfazinden
faydalanabiliyorum
indeksle
ya da
türle
structured
binding
faydalanabiliyorum
yine
tuple
interfazı
adı üstünde
tuple
interfazine
sahip olduğu için
tıpkı
stupeyre'de
stuveray'de
olduğu gibi
tuple'da da
arkadaşlar
structured
binding
faydalanabilirim
örneğin
bir fonksiyonumuzun
geri dönüş
tuple'ın
int virgül
double virgül
string
açılımı olsun
ben
bu fonksiyondan
aldığım
tuple'ı
doğrudan
kullanmak yerine
elemanlarına
ayrıştırmak
istiyorsam
auto
örneğin
id
wage
ve
name
eşittir
who
biçiminde
yazabilirim
structure binding
gibi ders ayrıntılı
anlatacağım
ama şimdilik
pair'inde
tuple'ında
stuveray'inde
structure binding'i
desteklediğine
ve
ilerleyen dakikalarda
anlatacağım
üzere
kendi
türlerimiz
içinde
kendi
custom
type'larımızın
structured binding'den
faydalanması için
kendi türümüze
yönelik
tuple
interfezi
destekleyen
öğeleri
oluşturabiliriz
böylece
kendi türlerimiz
içinde
structured binding'den
faydalanabiliriz
arkadaşlar
evet
konteynerlarda
şüphesiz
tuple
tutulabilir
yardımcı
fonksiyonumuz var
make tuple
arkadaşlar
bakın artık bu
fabrika fonksiyonlarını
anlamanız
zor değil
özellikle
sitat olmadan önce
daha fazla ihtiyaç
duyuluyordu
bakın bakın
izleyin
pamphlet
pipe name
arcs
arkadaşlar
make tuple
benimkini
biraz farklı olsun
make tuple
arcs
geri dönüş değeri
auto return
type
arcs
rep rep
return
subtuple
arcs
takip edebiliyor muyuz
evet
böyle bir fonksiyon
olduğunu düşünün
işte
böyle bir fonksiyon
olduğu için
örneğin
volt
pu
intx
double d
efendim
split string
s
geri dönüş değeri
make tuple
tıpkı
make
p gibi
arkadaşlar
make tuple
tabii kendisi
fonksiyon şablonu olduğu için
deduction yapılacak
x
d
s
yani
make tuple
fonksiyonu
bir
tuple
gönderiyor
arkadaşlar
yani
arc
deduction'dan
hani sınıf
şablonlarında
özellikle daha önceden
stat olmadığı için
template argümanlarını
yazmama için
hep bu
make fonksiyonları
ağırlıkla
kullanılıyordu
make
pair fonksiyonu
nasıl bir
pair oluşturuyorsa
bir pair oluşturan
fabrika fonksiyonuysa
arkadaşlar
bu
make tuple
fonksiyonu
da
bir
tuple
oluşturuyor
arkadaşlar
tuple'ın
karşılaştırma
fonksiyonları
pair'deki mantıkla
çalışıyor
yani
ilk öğeler
karşılaştırılıyor
de
mesela küçüktür
karşılaştırması
ilk öğesi
küçük olan
küçüktür
ilk öğeler
eşitse
ikinci öğesi
küçük olan
küçüktür
onlar da eşitse
üçüncü öğesi
küçük olan
küçüktür
ve bu
idiomatik bazı
yapılarda da
kullanılıyor
ama önce ben size
bunu göstermek için
şöyle bir
tuple oluşturayım
bakın bakın
tuple'ın
hatta şöyle yazalım
using
person
sözde
eşittir
tuple'ın
arkadaşlar
int virgül
string virgül
date açılımı
vektör başlık dosyasını da
dahil ediyorum
vektörün
person
açılımı
aspect
reserve
10 bin
tane
böyelik
yer ayırdım
şimdi
utility başlık dosyamızı
ekleyelim
ve
arkadaşlar
aspect
bir döngü
10 bin
kez dönen
aspect
and placeback
fonksiyonunu
herkes hatırlıyor
and placeback
iron
super
use
my rent
and placeback
random name
ve
date'in
randomı
böylece
tuple
vektörüme
10 bin
tane
tuple
ekledim
ve
tuple'daki
inti
stringi
ve date'i
rastgele
oluşturdum
ama
neden bunu yaptım
tahmin ediyorsunuz
less'in nasıl çalıştığını
görmenizi istiyorum
işte
karşılaştırma
tıkkı
PR'deki mantıklı
onu göstermek için
algoritm
başlık dosyasını
include
ediyorum
ve
sort
algoritmasında
küçük
den
büyüğe
sıralama
için
sort
begin
aspect
and
ekrandan
takip etmeniz
zor
olacağından
arkadaşlar
bu sefer
ne
yapıyorum
upstream
başlık dosyasını
dahil ediyorum
henüz dosya işlemlerini
göremesek de
range-based
forlook
kullanıyorum
for
const
bakın hem range-based
forlook
kullanacağım
hem de
structured binding
const
auto
ref
id
name
ve
nedir
arkadaşlar
ne olsun
b date
birth date
ve
aspect
neden
aspect oldu
ismi
hoş
verin
tamam
şimdi dosyaya yazdıracağım
arkadaşlar
dosyayı yazdırmak için
hadi
bugün bir değişiklik yapalım
c++
standardı ile
eklenen
stud formatı
kullanalım
evet
format
3 tane
yazdırıyorum
bu
id için
arkadaşlar
bu
isim için
bu da
date için
ama pardon
bunu yazmadık
o yüzden formatı
kullanmaktan
vazgeçtim
evet
o zaman
o fs
id
dosyamızı oluşturuyorum
out.tx'de her zaman olduğu gibi
zaten editörde açık
id
araya borçluk
name
borçluk
birth
date
eğer şimdilik
stud formatı
kullanmayacaksam
ionic
başlık dosyasını
ekliyorum
ve
önce
left
moduna
alıyorum
sonra
set v
parametreli
manipülatörüyle
set v
ne olsun
arkadaşlar
evet
id
karakterlik
alana
set v
karakterlik
alana
yazdırız
buralardaki detaylar
önemli değil
önemli olan dosyada gördünüz
bakın şimdi
ne dedik
ilk öğesi küçük olan
küçüktür
eşitse 2.
öğeye bakılacak
eşitse 3.
derleyip çalıştırıyorum
arkadaşlar
out.txt'ye bakın
arkadaşlar görüyorsunuz değil mi
bakın
küçükten büyüğü olduğu için
ilk öğesi küçük olanlar
önce sıfırlar
sonra birler
ama burada
örneğin 5'lere bakalım
tıpkı
Perdi olduğu gibi
bu sefer
Ahmet
Alparslan
küçükten büyüğe
ve bu seferde
5 Bekirlere
bakalım
5 Bekirlerde
tarihlerin
sırasıyla
gittiğini
görüyorsunuz
arkadaşlar bu da
aslında biraz
esprili şekilde
henüz benim size
anlatmadığım
eğer vakit yeterse
bu kursda yetmezse
ileri C++
kursunda
detaylı anlatıyorum
3 Way Comparison
Operator'ı
biraz daha
primitif versiyonu
o yüzden şöyle
diyorlar
poor man's
fakir adamın
spaceship
operatörü
arkadaşlar bakın
şimdi
zaten ben
büyük ihtimalle
date sınıfını
eğer
ben yazmışsam
ona göre yazmışım
ama
şimdi ben herhangi bir
date sınıfı üstünden
göstereyim
çok güzel bir
ideomatik yapı
bu
class date
izleyin
bunlar
arkadaşlar
sınıfın
bere elemanları
diyelim ki
m'de
ayın günü
m-m-i
ay
m-y
yıl
member
day
month
member
year
sınıfa
bir küçüktür
operatör fonksiyonu
yazmak istiyorsunuz
şimdilik
member
function olsun
arkadaşlar
public
ya da
friends
free
function olsun
bakın
friends
bold
operatör küçük
böyle
friendlere
hidden
friend
deniyor
const
date
ref
d1
ya da
klasik
lhs
left hand side
times
date
ref
rhs
right hand side
arkadaşlar
şimdi
espraya bakın
çok şık
aslında
bizde şöyle
yazmak istiyoruz
yılı küçük
olan küçük
yılları eşitse
ayı küçük
olan küçük
ay da eşitse
günü küçük
olan küçük
buraya
if deyimleri
ya da
turner
operatörle
doldurmak
yerine
tahmin edin
ne yapıyoruz
bakın
arkadaşlar
stup
tuple
lhs
m
ye
lhs
arkadaşlar
m
lhs
de
tabi
stattan
faydalanıyorum
eğer
c++
öncesi
olsaydı
arkadaşlar
belki
make couple
kullanabilirdim
küçük
rhs
e
zaten
tuple
karşılaştırması
böyle yapılmıyor
ama
o zaman
ne uğraşayım
zaten
bunlar
inline
extension
yapılacak
bir
maniyet
farkı
da olmayacak
doğrudan
tuple
karşılaştırmasının
ürettiği
değerle
ben de
geri dönüyorum
kodu
anladık mı
genel mantığında
anlamadığımız
bir şey var mı
buradaki
idiomatik
yapıya
biraz da bu
uydurma
bir terim
popüler
terim
fakir adamın
spaceship
operatörü
diyorlar
ama bence
çok etkili
bazı yerlerde
satır
kod
yazmak
yerine
yazılan
kodu
çok daha
basit
hale getiriyor
burayı
anladık mı
en az bir
arkadaşım
anladım
derse
yoksa
tekrar
açıklayayım
evet
tamam
teşekkür ederim
şimdi devam
arkadaşlar
ben
tuple
interfejden
bahsetmiştim
burası
özellikle
çok önemli
bundan sonra
öğreneceğimiz
bazı konular için
çok önemli
arkadaşlar
bakın
tuple
interfej
dediğim
aslında
3 tane
öveden
oluşuyor
biri
get
yani
indexle
çalışan
get
fonksiyonu
biri
buraya
dikkat
tuple
size
meta
fonksiyonu
diğeri de
tuple
element
meta
fonksiyonu
arkadaşlar
eğer
tabi bunlar
tuple
başlık
dosyasında
dikkat
arkadaşlar
eğer
tuple
size'ın
bir
tuple
açılımının
hadi onu
göstermek için
türe eşitsin
bildirimi yapalım
bakın
using
tp
mesela tp
tür ismi
arkadaşlar
ya da tp
type
diyelim
eşittir
suit
tuple'ın
int
double
char
açılımı
sadece beni
izleyin
tuple
size'ın
arkadaşlar
eğer
destekliyorsa
bir
tür açılımı
örneğin
tuple açılımı
tp
type
tuple
zaten
destekliyor
onun
values'u
tuple'daki
öğe sayısı
ve bu
tabi ki
compile
time
sabiti
yani
örneğin
constexpr
auto
sz
eşittir
dersem
compile
time
derleyici
sz'nin
değerinin
3 olduğunu
anlayacak
bakın
sz'nin
değeri
eğer
burada
örneğin
bir
argüman
daha olsaydı
stup
string
bu sefer
tuple
size'ın
tp
type'ının
values'u
kaç
olacaktı
cevap
izleyin
şimdi
4 olduğunu
görüyorsunuz
tabi ki
böyle durumlarda
daha önce
defalarca
örneğini
gördük
bir de
variable
template var
işi kolaylaştırmak
için
variable
template
nasıl
isimlendiriliyordu
aynı
meta
fonksiyon'da
fakat
underscore
v
geliyordu
dolayısıyla
böyle yazmakla
izleyiniz
tuple
size
underscore
v
value
açılımı
arkadaşlar
value
elemanına
erişmek
için
doğrudan
tuple size
underscore
v
tp
type
specialization
kullanabilirsiniz
anlaşıldı
değil mi
yine
4 olduğunu
görüyorsunuz
burayı biraz daha
dikkatli izlememiz
gerekiyor
şimdi
tuple size
meta
fonksiyon'ı
anladık
değil mi
tuple size
meta
fonksiyon
ama
tuple size
underscore
v
bu
variable
template
arkadaşlar
bir de
tuple
element var
bu da
tuple
interfazinin
bir bakka
üyesi
tuple
elementte
dürü
elde
etmek için
kullandığımız
meta
fonksiyon
fakat
bu
iki tane
template
parametresi
var
izleyin
tuple
elementin
ilk
template
parametresi
non-type
parametre
indeksi
veriyorsunuz
örneğin
bir indeksi
arkadaşlar
ikinci template
parametresi
olarak
tuple
veriyorsunuz
yani
tp
type
arkadaşlar
ve
bunun
type'ı
o öğenin
türü
şimdi
söyleyin bakalım
anladıysanız
o zaman
24.
satıra
yazdığım
tür
hangi tür
cevap
double türü
öyle değil mi
bakın
bir indeksi
yani örneğin
ben
bu türden
bir değişken
tanımlasam
hangi türden
değişken
tanımlamış
olacağım
arkadaşlar
double türden
değişken
tanımlamış
olacağım
deniz anlaşıldı mı
bakın
x'in türü
double
eğer
sıfır
olsaydı
bu durumda
int türü
olacaktı
olsaydı
char türü
olacaktı
arkadaşlar
olsaydı
stut
string
olacaktı
tabi ki
burada da
genel konvensiyon
gereği
arkadaşlar
teşekkür ederim
bazen
kimse bir şey
yazmayınca
kendimi çok
yalnız hissediyorum
burada
type
nested
type'ına
erişmek
için
bu seferde
alias template
tahmininin
tuple element
underscore t'nin
bu sefer
template argümanlarıyla
specialization'ı
type'ın
kendisini veriyor
burada da
alias template
kullanıyor
yani
yine
örneğin
böyle bir değişken
tanımlasaydım
string
türünden
olacaktı
değişkenim
arkadaşlar
şimdi bakın
bir şey
dikkatinizi
çekecek mi
neler
structured
binding'i
destekliyordu
cevap
yani
bizim şimdiye
kadar
görneklerimizde
tuple
doğal olarak
pair
studeray
doğru mu
bunlar
sınıf
olmalarına
rağmen
structure
binding'i
destekliyor
şimdi bir şey
deneyelim
izleyin
using
type
eşittir
stud pair'in
int virgül
double açılımı
bakın bakın
tuple elementin
ya da önce
tuple size'ın
arkadaşlar
type açılımının
values'u
tahmin edin
kaç olacak
ilk cevap
görüyor musunuz
ya da
tuple size
underscore v'nin
type açılımı
gördünüz mü
ya da şuna bakınız
tuple elementin
0 virgül
type açılımının
type
member'ı
tabii ki
int
yani burada
neyi göstermek
istiyorum
pekala
gördüğünüz gibi
stud pair'de
tuple
interfeasini
destekliyor
ama
bir de
studeray'e
bakalım
izleyin
arkadaşlar
acaba studeray'ı
destekliyor mu
using type
eşittir
studeray'in
arkadaşlar
int virgül
açılımı
tuple element
önce
tuple size
bu sefer
kısa
keseceğim
tuple size
underscore v'nin
pipe açılımı
arkadaşlar
compile time
sabiti
5 olduğunu
görüyorsunuz
tuple
element
virgül
type
açılımının
tuple
element
underscore
t'nin
0 virgül
type
açılımının
yine
eri'in
elemanlarının
türü olan
int türü
olduğunu
görüyorsunuz
arkadaşlar
biraz erken
olsa da
aslında
kendi
türümüz
içinde
bunu yapabiliriz
bakın
mesela
date için
yapalım
bu önemli
dikkat
yine
mülakatların
tipik
soruları
arasında
c++
programcısının
ben şimdi
giriş neteliğinde
anlatacağım
ileri c++
da çok daha
detaylı anlatıyorum
arkadaşlar
izleyin
şöyle bir şey
yapmak istiyorum
bakın
mesela bir fonksiyon
var
date
u
ya da
date
get date
return
herhangi bir fonksiyon
şimdi
soru
ben date
türü için
doğrudan
structured
binding
kullanabilir miyim
cevap
hayır
eğer bu
basit bir
structure
olsaydı
cevap
evet
olurdu
ama
burada
hayır
mesela şöyle
bir şey yazabilir miyim
auto
day
man
year
eşittir
arkadaşlar
get date
şununla
küçük
arka yapalım
bunu legal
kılmak
istiyorum
arkadaşlar
işte işin
sırrı ne
bunu
legal
kılmak
için
kendi
türünüzünde
neye
destek
olması
gerekiyor
söyleyin
tuple
interfeisinin
sağlaması
gerekiyor
tuple
interfeisinin
sağlaması
ne demek
yanıt
arkadaşlar
tuple
size'ı
implemente
edecek
tuple
element'i
implemente
edecek
ve get
fonksiyonlarını
implemente
edecek
takip edebiliyor
muyuz
tabi bunları
implemente
etmenin
bir daha fazla
yolu var
arkadaşlar
en basiti
tuple
element ve
size için
ne yapmak
bunlar
metafunkçınlar
ya
bunları
explicit
specialization
ile oluşturmak
o zaman
örneğin
önce
tuple
size'ı
oluşturalım
arkadaşlar
izleyin
templates
diamond
struct
stut
tuple
size'ın
date
açılımı
başlık
dosyasını
dahil ettik
mi
evet
const
text
tl
struct
size
t
value
eşit
bir
üç
statik
takip edebiliyor
muyuz
artık
tuple
size'ın
date
açılımı
da var
öyle değil mi
bakın
daha önce
yoktu
bu
ama
şimdi
tuple
size'ın
using
bildirimini
de yapalım
tuple
size'ın
date
açılımının
values'u
artık
işte
yukarıdaki
explicit
specialization
ile
üç
oldu
hatta
variable
template
de
oluşturabilirim
template
arkadaşlar
izleyin
tut
size'ın
tuple
size
underscore
ve
neyse
şimdilik
variable
template
oluşturmayalım
çünkü
zaten
kullanmayacağız
ama
tabii
variable
template
oluşturmayı
da
zaten
öğrendik
anlaşıldı
değil mi
yani
ben
tuple
size'ın
date
açılımının
values'u
demek yerine
tuple
size
underscore
v'nin
efendim
date
açılımı
diyebilirdim
yani
variable
template'i nasıl
oluşturduğumuzu
biliyorsunuz
değil mi
template
type name
t
efendim
stud
yine de
gösterelim
size t
arkadaşlar
tuple
size
underscore
v'nin
date
açılımı
tuple
size
underscore
v
tabii
bunun için
de
specialization
oluşturabilirim
tuple
size
v'nin
efendim
şuraya
stud
gelecek
date
açılımı
constexpr
eşittir
arkadaşlar
stud
tuple
size
vesaire
yani
daha önce öğrendik
pek hepsini
yazmıyorum
biraz da zaman
sıklaması var
evet efendim
tuple size'ın
date
açılımının
values'u var
şimdi gelelim
tuple
elementi
e
burada işimiz
kolay
çünkü
üçünün
türü de
int
o yüzden
burada
tuple
elementi
doğrudan
şöyle
yazabilirim
template
non-type
parametre
stud
size t
arkadaşlar
efendim
stud
size t
n
partial
specialization
oluşturuyorum
struct
tut
tuple
elementin
arkadaşlar
n
virgül
date
açılımı
burada da
using
pipe
eşittir
int
çünkü
benim üç
elemanımda
int
dolayısıyla
tuple elementin
0 virgül
date açılımı
da int
tuple elementin
1 virgül
date açılımı
da int
2 virgül
date açılımı
da int
hatta
istersen
buraya bir
statik
asert de
koyabilirim
statik
asert
bunu da henüz
görmedik
n
efendim
küçüktür
bu da tamam
şimdi geriye ne kaldı
get fonksiyonları
kaldı
get fonksiyonlarında
yine
arkadaşlar
ya
her bir
indeks için
ayrı bir
explicit
specialization
oluşturacağım
ya da
tek bir
get fonksiyonu
yazacağım
yani
şöyle yazabilirim
örneğin
pamphlet
stud
size t
n
arkadaşlar
auto
get
evet
önce get'in
0 açılımı
1 açılımı
2 açılımı
olacak
öyle değil mi
parametresi
arkadaşlar
date
ref
const date
dt
if
cortex
br
n
eşit
0 ise
return
arkadaşlar
n
dt
0 neydi
gündü
month day
tabi
bunu doğrudan
sınıfın içinde
büye fonksiyonu da
yapabilirdim
member template de
else
if
mox expr
n
eşit eşit
return
dt
month
asil
const
expr
n
eşit eşit
return
dt
year
evet
artık
tuple
interfezini
desteklemesi
gereken
bütün
üyeleri
yazdık
yani
tuple
size
için
bir
specialization
oluşturduk
tuple
element
için
yine
bir
specialization
oluşturduk
partial
specialization
bu ise
explicit
specialization
ve get
fonksiyonunu
non type
parametre ile
implement
ettik
ve şimdi
arkadaşlar
şuraya
bakalım
auto
day
month
year
eşittir
get date
artık
ne olacak
arkadaşlar
geçerli olacak
toplu interfezi
desteklendiği için
bir dahaki derste
çalışır hale
getirin
çarşamba
günkü dersimizi
peki
bugünkü dersimiz
burada sona eriyor
derse katıldığınız
için teşekkür
ediyorum
çarşamba
günü
görüşmek üzere
herkese
iyi akşamlar
diliyorum
hoşçakalın
değerli arkadaşlar
abone ol